this is Jocko podcast number 223 with
echo Charles and me Jocko Willing good
evening echo good evening modern combat
is chaotic
intense and shockingly destructive in
your first battle you will experience
the confusing and often terrifying
sights sounds smells and dangers of the
battlefield but you must learn to
survive and win despite them one you
could face a fierce and relentless enemy
two you could be surrounded by
destruction and death three your leaders
and fellow soldiers may shout urgent
commands and warnings for rounds might
impact near you five the air could be
filled with the smell of explosives and
propellant six you might hear the
screams of a wounded comrade however
even in all this confusion and fear
remember that you are not alone you are
part of a well-trained team backed by
the most powerful combined arms force
and the most modern technology in the
world
you must keep faith with your fellow
soldiers remember your training and do
your duty to the best of your ability if
you do and you uphold your Warrior Ethos
you can win and return home with honor
this is the soldiers Field Manual it
tells the soldier how to perform the
combat skills needed to survive on the
battlefield all soldiers across branches
and components must learn these basic
skills noncommissioned officers must
ensure that their soldiers receive
training on and know these vital combat
skills
so that right there is the opening
introduction of the US Army Field Manual
three tact 21.7 five the Warrior Ethos
and soldier combat skills and after that
intro the Field Manual itself is just
filled with these skills vast skills
that are the backbone of being a good
soldier things like this things like
combat casualty care and casualty
evacuation how to work in the desert in
the jungle in arctic conditions how to
use cover concealment and camouflage how
to prepare fighting positions fighting
positions in urban environments fighting
positions in rural environments
immediate actions fire and movement fire
moon on foot and fire movement in
vehicles things like how to move
effectively through open areas how to
get past windows how to maneuver around
corners how to enter a building clear a
room how to conduct reconnaissance
missions how to shoot a variety of
weapons and not just shoot them but how
do you battle zero those weapons how do
you use reflexive fire what are your
immediate actions on failure of your
weapon systems and of course there's
communications you got to learn a bunch
of different radios and radio force
voice procedures and then on top of that
you got you've got the classic survival
evasion resistance escape in the event
that you get captured
what about Camelot chemical biological
and Radiological weapons how do you face
those how do you what are the
decontamination and treatment procedures
for all those what about mines
what about demolitions what are
breaching procedures
what about IEDs how do you identify them
how do you find them how do you disarm
and destroy them
those are some of the things you need to
learn and on top of all that what about
your Army Values what about the law of
land warfare the Code of Conduct the
soldier's creed and the Warrior Ethos
this manual is packed and that is a lot
to learn it's a lot to track and quite
frankly what that manual covers is the
basics the fundamentals that's like the
starting point because there are
countless skills beyond those
fundamentals and the longer that a
soldier stays on task the longer he
stays operational the more proficient he
becomes at those fundamental skills and
then moves on to advanced skills that
have tighter standards and more detail
and more modalities and one thing about
being a soldier is you never you never
master it there's too much there's too
many things to know too many things to
understand too many things to practice
too many things to rehearse too many
things to exercise and too many things
to execute to be truly good at these and
I'll tell you what these skills they're
not only applicable to soldiers they're
all applicable to life they're all
useful in life and maybe it's because
there's so much sometimes sometimes
people sometimes soldiers sometimes
servicemen and women they let those
skills slide as time goes on they become
softer they weaken but there are some
soldiers and some people that continue
to strive that continue to push that
continue to try become faster and
stronger and more skilled and more
accurate and more lethal
and they never stop aspiring to be their
best and and those those are the true
sentinels of freedom who not only strive
to be their best but also pass on their
knowledge to others that's what they do
with their lives and it's an honor to
have one of those sentinels with us here
tonight retired Special Forces soldier
tactical shooting instructor and
all-around highly skilled and capable
combat veteran Pat McNamara Pat brother
thank you so much for having me I really
appreciate the opportunity yeah man
thanks for coming on it's uh I know we
linked up I forget how you sent me a
message I sent you a message or
something and we'll it but you finally
were able to come out here and you know
you said hey you're gonna be around I'm
like I can make it happy you know the
community of the interwebs right I mean
some really great people I mean
outstanding people with great character
and all positive attributes so and when
I meet him like you for example oh I
knew knew through is through the
interwebs never we never met in person
but you could siphon through the
[ __ ] and tell whether or not
somebody's legit and whether they're you
know whether they're honorable person
whether they got good work ethic and all
that [ __ ] so the people I meet I'm very
fortunate to have met some great people
because of the the interwebs and you're
one of them so thank you so much for
making this happen so
you and I got some things in common one
of us we both got in the military pretty
quick we also both grew up in New
England yeah so let's go let's go right
to the beginning cool where this started
you grew up in Connecticut yep and what
date were you a sport we're athlete
you know what I I started out like my
early black twins years kind of um I was
an odd kid when I was an oddball you
know I was I was probably uh my dad was
probably disappointed but he supported
all my oddball [ __ ] that I wanted to do
I mean I had all the suzie hobbies
really I was not an athlete I was I was
uh I was the kid who got picked on no
kid yeah I mean I would ride he's like
yeah yeah
there was a reason for it and there was
a time when I went through a
metamorphosis and I had it was like a
sink or swim type of thing but you know
I would ride a unicycle to school I drew
I watch birds I pick flowers all that
stuff and yeah I was I was a big-time
[ __ ] and then I had a I had a window of
opportunity to get tough and I had some
mentors in my neighborhood who pointed
me down a road and the window of
opportunity was it was basically a like
survival because I had an older brother
who tormented me I mean he was horrible
person and when he went to prison the
first time I was bright at like 15 years
old so you know as a teenager you know
you're growing you you have the capacity
to really grow and be somebody and I had
neighbors and said hey man what are you
gonna do with this time you have this
time and I didn't even think of it as
that I had no idea what they were
talking about you have this time to to
to prepare for his reap you know for him
to come back home you have time so um
yeah I started wrestling that was a big
thing and the wrestling turned me around
and my first two years I suck but my
second two years I was I was badass
my senior I could not be beaten because
I fell in love with it and I would go to
the college during the summers and
practice with the college students that
kind of thing and I was lifting weights
and and
you know running back and forth to work
and stuff like that so I was able to
like self-govern I didn't need anybody
to drive me because I saw the results I
saw what was happening I saw the change
got in a couple street fights so that
you know you learn you learn whether or
not you could cut the mustard in the
neighborhood based on you know who's
who's picking a fight with you and how
and what the results are whether you're
getting your ass beat with humility or
you're kicking somebody's ass either way
you know you learning a lot about
yourself what you do in the street
fights double leg slam
yeah I'm sound Li exactly double leg
takedown you know to a dump to a
headlock to a couple punches in the face
yep exactly those were the you know they
talk about like the good old days you
you know the good old days we didn't use
guns and knives
whatever hey in the good old days it was
just double leg headlock that's right
that's what a street fight was yeah
there wasn't any of this jujitsu or Muay
Thai no double leg headlock yeah punches
to the face I tell you you had a real
vanish if you know a really better fight
you know back then because you know back
then I think fight training was you know
Taekwondo or just stuff like that
it was karate yeah yeah there was no
like Muay Thai and Jiu Jitsu and stuff
so if you were wrestling yeah you had a
big advantage on the street yeah there
was a there was a guy when I was a new
guy at SEAL team one there was like a
guy that had a reputation of being a
fighter cuz he was some kind of some
kind of karate guy or something like
that and this is this is the 90s right
this isn't that long ago but it's before
UFC one so people kind of thought well
you know if you did karate man I
wouldn't you know that I mean you know
and and there was a little Interpol tune
scrapped between the Karate Kid will say
and on a kid that was a wrestler right
on and a good wrestler like a state
champ
yeah from and Westerner or something he
you know was exactly what what happened
in the fight the Karate Kid got his
karate stance and
Resler did a double leg slam headlock
punch right and everyone's like Dave
Andy what's crazy is now that I'm
thinking about it even back then it was
kind of like well that must have just
been you know a fluke that the Kurt that
the karate kid didn't do whatever a damn
Mach kill him all the spots so so so
wrestling was huge huge for you yeah big
yeah massive so that really that changed
that changed me in every every way
you know both physically and mentally it
just and it's so funny because I talk a
lot a lot I talk about a lot with
different Special Op guys and one of the
big common denominators is most of them
were wrestlers in high school you know
or a really big percentage of more
wrestlers in high school because I think
it it that's the one sport where even
though you're on a team you know you're
not relying on a team or you you're
representing a team and you're earning
points toward for your team and you have
to be a team player but you have to be
self driven to you know you have if you
want to be the best you have to think
well I need to do a thousand reps of
this thing I need to get my grip
strength better I need better balance I
need to do more sprints I need you know
to increase my shoulders strength
whatever it is you know you have to you
have to be very introspective unlike you
know cuz I played other sports and and
there's some there's some common ground
with them too but but with the wrestling
you know you're mano a mano with another
dude for that six minutes and time and
that's a long freakin six minutes at the
go situation I'm gonna [ __ ] you know
what else is and there's another big
thing a big psychological thing and my
son just just wrapped up his season to
end you know what the season didn't end
how he wanted it to end
yeah and his coach who's a great guy
came up to me you know in and he you
know just standing there you know I was
bummed out but I'm not like super
emotional
about the thing but his coach comes up
and says I said yeah it's a bad day and
he goes yeah it's a bad day to have a
bad day and I said yeah and he goes
wrestling very rarely ends the way you
want it to yeah and if you think about
that you know you go into a 64 man
bracket there's one person that that day
ends the way they wanted it to or two
days and then guess what that person's
going to the next tournament right and
what are the chances that so really and
when you get done with the season if
you're the champion for the season guess
what that means you've got another
season coming up and eventually
eventually you're not gonna be happy
with the outcome right that's what's
gonna happen so what's what I love about
it is you know especially like you're
saying your freshman sophomore year
you're just getting beat down yeah and
so many kids I see there in the
wrestling program they that first year
you know if they're getting beat down
because they've never us before they
can't take it the other clearly quitting
and they quit but people that are tough
and they look at themselves and say well
I least see how I can get myself better
yep how'd it work out when your brother
got home it it turned out really really
well um he I was upstairs at the top of
the stairwell and I was in the bathroom
I was taking a dump was he in juvie or
was no no no so he was in the bigge was
state he was he went to the plate he
went to the Penn State Penn I'll think
about the name cuz you'll remember it
you'll know that the name of the town
and everything it'll it'll hit me but he
came upstairs and basically kicked the
bathroom door open and I'm sitting down
I'm sitting down it's like the ultimate
bully him yep yeah and I'm intimidated
and I'm and I'm now I'm embarrassed too
because I got my pants around my ankles
and I said hey you know get the hell out
here
and he turns he I could tell he's stoned
out of his mind and he's got his fist in
my face you know one of those say I want
to say hello and I pulled my pants up
and I said you won't what tonight
freaking just straight right just
straight overhand right BAM and it went
almost through his face and he went down
the stairs and then what did i do I
followed him downstairs
he got up double leg takedown headlock
and my parents were sitting in the
kitchen and um they crossed their legs
and just watched it happen they were
like it's about time this guy this is up
in comments right here you know this is
Karma yeah they didn't do a thing so I
got you know those Blixen and told them
goodbye and looking out the door because
I was going out and was that your senior
year
that was my junior year yep at what
point did you start looking at the at
the military that year yeah I know I sew
it in yeah junior year 1617 is when I
knew I had to I had to do that I had no
idea what anything was with the military
so it's funny because when I went to the
recruiters I didn't tell my dad and I
went to all the recruiters I had no prep
I had no I had no preference it wasn't
like I had Allegiance because you know
somebody's dad was in the Marine Corps
forever or or Ward the army colors or
anything like that I didn't care I just
wanted I want to be a tough guy so I
went to each one of the cruisers and and
the vetting process was who could
fast-track me who could put me on a road
to badassery
the fastest I wanted a fast track to
badassery so at the time the army had
the best answer because they had two
programs they had Rangers and then they
had the s a baby program 18 x-ray so um
I signed up for that and I went home and
told my dad my dad was like he was a
little put off because I didn't tell him
he said hey we're going we're going back
there but I'm bringing my lawyer because
I don't want this guy to [ __ ] you and
sure [ __ ] man when I went back with a
lawyer he was doing some scrambling with
the paperwork yeah he was he was
changing some numbers or digits around
or whatever that's I'm so glad that my
dad hooked me up like that you know
because it could have gone really bad I
did it mostly day I mean it's it's so
funny it's it's so funny because I look
at that career and
and you have to be so lucky you know
with us and I tell all the UH all these
guys who you know contact me on the
interwebs and stuff they say hey I want
to be a CEO I want to be a forestry
count all this stuff and it's hard to
explain to them the amount not only how
how tenacious you have to be but the
amount of luck involved in that road I
say guys this is it it's a good road to
take it's a bumpy road there's no
shortcuts but it's a well it's a road
worth taking but damn man I mean because
the amount of times I failed throughout
my 22-year career I could write a book
just on failures you know on the amount
of [ __ ] that I failed it had to go back
and do again yeah the of injuries and
the recoveries and the surgeries and
another failure another failure another
failure and I mean and and it's easy
it's pretty easy to go well I failed
that one so I'm probably just not cut
out for that thing but with most Special
Ops guys they don't stop at one thing
they don't like for instance become
Airborne Ranger and say well this is it
this is pinnacle I'm peaking out here
I'm gonna just accept this I mean it's a
great career path but most of them say
what's the next step you know what's the
next step let me go and see if I could
you know go to halo school let me go to
combat dive school let me go to SF
course
let me try out for selection and go to
the unit you know for most of them they
want to keep progressing and progressing
and progressing so the opportunity in
the and the not the opportunity but the
chance the chances of failure become
greater and greater because you know
you're volunteering over and over and
over so whenever I talk to young kids
and they want to be you know they have
it they have it in their mind I want to
be a CEO I'm like that's great but just
understand you know I'm all about it and
and and you know if you've got a good if
you got a good but it's hot the hard
part is for me is to tell them there's a
lot of luck involved
yeah I thought you were gonna say
there's no shortcuts and there's no
guarantee that's that's that's it two
throws yeah just like that road there's
no shortcuts on that road yeah yeah
that's why one thing that I a pretty
much one thing I try not to do is say
yep you should do right
yeah because and well and the worst
thing about the Navy and going for the
SEAL Teams is look if that's what the
kind of lifestyle you want to live do
you want to carry a machine gun that's
great right if you don't make it in the
SEAL Teams then you're not carrying a
machine gun right at all right hey if
you don't make it through SF or you
don't make it as a ranger you don't make
it to Force Recon you can still be a
grunt which is awesome right and that's
what you want to do I want to be a grunt
since I was born so so when I joined the
Navy I never thought about that I didn't
even recognize that I was too dumb but
it's it's no guarantee there's no
shortcut and man yeah it takes luck you
you land wrong on a jump you you know
get hurt for in in the basic SEAL
training there's something called Rock
portage where there's big waves your
landing boats in these giant rocky area
and it's no fence and it's too easy just
to step off rock wave hits your knees
blown out yeah two years of recovery you
put on weight you're fat you're out of
shape you know you go back you get
stress fractures you're done I think
that happens all the time yeah it
happens all the time that was I was a
towed jumper my second job I was 18
years old I was a freakin toad jump I
got towed all the way across France drop
zone I pull my bicep into my forearm
broke my ribs dislocated shoulder
concussion I mean I was jacked up and I
just joined
that was my first failure that was
number one then that set me back bro
yeah that in that airplane again who who
was at what number jump was that for you
number 200 I still had three left of
three or four whatever it is in jump
school so toe jumper is that's that's
just a nightmare
yeah and they briefed it all time I've
never even I've never seen one yeah
they briefed at all time so talk us
through
talk us through being a toad jumper and
well for I mean for people who don't
know you know when you start out a jump
career that's how you start with a swift
static line so the static line is hooked
to an inboard cable inside the aircraft
and when you jump out of the airplane
you hit the it the the end of the static
line and it deploys your chute if it
pulls a shoot out and subsequently you
know the chute inflates and you float to
the ground straight down it's a round
chute there's not a lot of skill
involved yeah and the key part is that
that once that static line pulls the
chute out it lets go right they're not
connected right so it just pulls the
chute out the chute is now inflated and
the static line stays with the aircraft
that's the aircraft yep so there's many
different weight right that's what's
supposed to happen there's a lot of
different ways you could become a towed
jumper one is it's a it's a fault of the
rigger so the rigger did something and
there's a knot somewhere within the you
know the lines of the canopy or what
have you so those are pretty rare
another the more common one is a fall to
the jumper you know so the jumper does
something wrong you know he he doesn't
hand it to the do to the to the safety
the right way his static line because as
you as you're going down you know the
aircraft toward the door you've got the
static line in your hand and the last
step before you exit is to hand it to to
safety the jump master and he collects
it up and he you know pushes him away
from the jumpers so it's it's it's it's
all very well rehearsed and it's
choreographed in it there's a lot of
Theodore to it looks cool
so I must have just like chucked it at
him and it got away from and it went
like under my reserve and around my arm
so I am NOT even halfway I'm at the
beginning of the stick double doors
c-130 I'm at the beginning of the stick
I go out and instant fire through my
whole body inst
I go to hit the end of the static line
and I feel my whole body just jerk and
go with the aircraft I was lucky that
the static line was under my reserve and
not just around the arm because that
would you know meirin would just come
off bro you know but uh so it's under
the reserve around the arm so there was
some friction there with the static line
around the equipment the rest of it was
around my arm and I remember I had the
whereabouts to look up the length of the
static line and I could see jumpers
coming over the top of me but this
wasn't now don't get me wrong this was
not me beat I was scared shitless you
know I was looking up going oh my god
you know this is I was horrified it was
a you know an omen of horn and over over
over I could see jumpers jumping over me
and I'm going what in the hell you know
the training said you know put your
hands on your reserve and wait to get
pulled in and all this stuff and and and
I'm not remembering uni because I can't
do this I can't put my cuz your arms to
your arms up yeah always your arms like
tangled in the static line yep oh yeah
now and the most of the tension is
around the reserve hmm but some and I
keep hitting the airplane so thankfully
I just so everyone knows cuz you're in
130 140 mile an hour wind yep that's
what's that's what's toss in your ass
so I'm getting slammed up against the
aircraft and thankfully I get slammed
hard enough and it comes loose so I've
you know fall under the static line boom
chute deploys had that not happened
there's no way I would have had to wear
about support over my reserve no freakin
way cuz I was already you know shocky
you know the body's amazing you know
when you reach you know pain level 10
the body would compensate you know and
says let's take care of you and put you
into some shock here so you know so you
don't feel that bad but I remember being
very very uncomfortable under canopy and
I was groaning and moaning just Oh
just moaning and groaning and I was all
the way at the end a friar and how it's
supposed to be like way up at the
leading edge I was all the way at the
end I mean right like at the wood line
and I hit the ground and I land on that
side boom right on those ribs and all
that soft [ __ ] right on that arm now to
add insult to injury I'm laying there
and I'm going you know I'm just 18 euro
punky kid bro you know I've done nothing
but basic training and AIT to add insult
to injury I'm laying there on the ground
and a breeze comes in place oh shoot it
fades and it starts dragging me across
fire drop zone and I'm getting drugged
boom boom and I can hear you know the
black hat so the instructors out there
would we stand on these platforms with
bull horns and they were you know placed
throughout this massive what's fry our
drop sounds like a two-minute drop zone
or something he's gigantic its massive
and I could hear one of these black cat
instructors yelling at me get up leg you
over there getting drugged released one
of your care to be rude can't be
released assemblies now leg and I'm
going oh my god I better do what he says
cuz I'm gonna get in trouble
so I do that I reach up and pop pop one
of my cable loop type can if you release
assemblies and and I'm scared I'm scared
cuz I think I'm gonna get in trouble
mmm-hmm you know cuz I'm hurt and and I
didn't get permission to get hurt this
is the first time I was ever injured
injured injured in my life you know real
injury uh I packed all my [ __ ] up you
know I packed all that crap up into that
kit bag threw it on my back and I
remember being really really scared
because there was no signal from my head
to my arm you know there was no
transmission to make it move to make it
worse and then I remember feeling my
face and feeling blood that was
superficial but you know I hit that the
cut was superficial but I hit hard you
know against the aircraft boom boom
boom over and over and so I get all my
[ __ ] and I pack it up and I bring it all
into the turnin area and the black hats
are scanned in the crowd cuz they know
and somebody's [ __ ] i yeah they saw it
and they're scanning the crowd and I'm
going oh my god nobody comes up to my to
me he goes hey bro you look bad cuz I
was I guess just ashen white you know
and I'm dry healy and stuff and and I
look look at my arm and he could see
that there was the old school BTUs like
genuine BTUs I had rope burns around and
I go yeah man I'm hurt really bad I
don't I don't feel good and he said let
me help you with that
you know button my blouse and he looked
and that's when I flew up because now
I'm looking at this on and there wasn't
open but it was like translucent the
skin and there was no bicep and he kept
pulling it down a boom there it was in
my form you know and so the black hats
see that and they come running over you
the guy yeah yeah yeah well the medevac
already took off with some dude with a
broken femur and the bird already took
off so they had to bust me back on these
blue bird bus school buses all the way
to Martin Army Hospital and then to add
more insult to injury this is 1983 so
there's a bunch of dudes in there with
Grenada injuries like real jump injuries
you know in the hospitals filled with
these dudes man with Rangers and guys
from 82nd who have like real combat jump
injuries and I'm here with this tow
jumper school 45th company duffel bag
drag you know injury and I was like oh
my god this sucks so bad that's
beginning I mean I had but but there was
a lot of times like that you know in my
in my like I said I could write a book
of fun on how many times I have failed
but they're funny so I try to make I try
to make it interesting and funny how did
you just to rewind a little bit
what did you do to get ready what did
you know about Special Forces training
and what did you do to get ready prior
to going in well I didn't have I had oh
prior to going in there alright so I was
wrestling
I was lifting weights I was doing a lot
of hiking you know like camping and is
that because you knew like yeah I knew
they were part of it yep I knew that
they were woods men and stuff like that
I had a buddy who was uh he was I was a
boy scout I had a buddy who was Eagle
Scout and knew all the mountaineering
stuff he was really good and we would go
up and do robes and rappelling and all
that you know it also good for fear
management when you're a kid you know
rappelling off the side of a cliff is
great stuff to help carpa
compartmentalize those you know fears of
heights and things like that but I did a
lot of Woods running you know and just I
think for me it was therapeutic and it
was more about mental preparation than
physical preparation physically I was
pretty freaking strong I was I was very
fit I was a very fit teenager you know
and my my latter teen years 17 18 years
old I was very self driven I wanted to
be fit I saw that you know that I looked
cool too you know and that's a freaking
motivator Pro when you're 17 and 18 and
when you got a physique
it's like yep how many I needed I need
to work out more because damn good yeah
now when you got in what was the shock
to your system like day two of boot camp
so regular boot camp that was that was
scary as hell I love it how how you know
it's all theater mmm
but you don't know that no you have no
idea but here's the thing to day two it
was actual day to say they had the the
rules weren't in place yet in 1983 where
there there there came a point where
drill sergeants couldn't physically you
didn't hit you yeah that point hadn't
happened yet mm-hmm and I watched a
drill sergeant right hook or a dude who
you know made a move at him in formation
you know one of my peers private nothing
he's zero and he was that parade rest
and the drill started was yelling at him
and they were both sized for size you
know they both looked like badasses I
remember looking at this this punky kid
and this Joe son they both looked like
badasses and the kid you know made a
jump boom and I'm out of nowhere
I mean hook right to the frickin jaw
timber drop boom just dropped and our
holy that was the scariest thing I ever
saw
I've never seen that in my life before
you know like that I mean I've saw some
street fights but that you know mano y
mano that that fearless guy and that
hook was so freakin fast and then seeing
that guy just timber was yeah I was I
was pretty scared I know I know that
when people listen to podcast and
they'll send me a message and be like
hey i just joined i just do an army it's
join the Marine Corps just join the Navy
and I always say listen the first two
weeks you're saying thank you right now
the first two weeks you're gonna be like
hating right you're gonna wish you never
listen to this podcast because it's such
a shock to your system to have every
freedom that you have as a human being
every sense of individuality and every
sense of privacy which is like three
some of the three primary things that we
value they're all gone they're gone
stripped away
it's a great culture shock I love the
way they do it you know I love it the
culture shock is is real you know and if
you're not used to it you know just some
punky kid who is badass on the wrestling
team and then you you know then your
heads get shaved off and then you you
look the same as everybody else and then
you know you're sleep-deprived
sleep-deprived what is that you know and
you have the time limit to eat and all
you know and then the constant freakin
yelling and screaming in your face yeah
I think they do they did well with the
infantry basic training when I went in
as I could remember call it now I say
kudos to those guys who are who are able
to run it like that I mean once again
all theater you know when I look back if
I were to go right now through it and
like yeah whatever I'll play your game
I know you're not gonna do anything to
me yeah just get a suck that's all I'm
thinking though 83 - you had a bunch of
Vietnam guys yes or nevermind still had
field not early Grenada yeah damn you
guys had shipped a lot I mean I had a
Nam Nam guys in when I got to the teams
but you know it had been 20 years right
so there's a lot of guys that retired at
20 well guys that just got out after
whatever they did two or three tours in
Vietnam but for you in 83 man it was
yeah cause you were they were a matter
of fact went out even when I went to the
SF course they were they were thick oh
hey Vietnam that's going through the SF
course Oh going through it dang yeah
they were thick and then when I got to a
team and first group you know my team
started was a 173rd guy you know in
Vietnam and they were they were a dime a
dozen I mean you had all of the command
were Vietnam if there were n cos you
know they were Vietnam that's if they
were east 7s and above they were all
Vietnam vets so how long did it take you
to recover from the Toth jumper scenario
jumper happened in October and I
finished jump school a couple months
later in end of February so you
recovered and then went back to jump
school no no that's when I ended jump
school yes I recovered and finished jump
school end of February is something like
that quick recovery yeah yeah yeah and
you had to get bicep surgery right yep
yep and it was a mess because I split
the bicep in half it wasn't like it's
separated from all the tendon it split
the bicep in half so they had to salvage
it so it's about as big as the way it
explains to me is a big as round as a
pencil so you can imagine the amount of
strength that you lose you know and you
don't know how much you rely on a bicep
when it's when it has to work in
compound with other months for instance
doing pull-ups because when I got to the
q course so now you're starting all the
freaking screaming and yelling and sleep
deprivation and food deprivation all
over yet all over you just finished it
but now you're doing more of it now
you're back to being you it straight
from jump school yoku course yep matter
of fact but yep right - and I started
the q course on my 19th birthday
March yes there was my birthday March
5th to 1984 I started the queue course
and our March sport and in can't recall
first days when they weren't screaming
and yell at you you're doing classes
patrolling in land nav and survival all
this stuff and you were able to get a
hot a one hot meal a day if you could do
10 pull-ups with your kid on and climb
the rope with your kid on and most
everybody was doing that I wasn't doing
it because I had no bicep and now this
hurt my pride because I'm fit you know I
mean I was a pull-up master but I just
finished all these months in the
hospital to hadn't done any PT nothing
you know so I had to get I had to get
back into shape while I was getting back
into shape you know during the training
process I had to I had to get into shape
because I was getting those hot rations
and I did it took a while but I got
those things and how long is AQ course
um for me it was a long time it was some
of it depends on what your MLS is like
your second phase and I don't know how
they run it now as far as like phases go
so there's a first phase which is all
the basic skills your land nav your
survival your patrolling all your
repelling all all that stuff you know
and and getting yelled at you know the
first phase just sucks just just a big
suck fest and there's classes in between
suckin second phase depends on what
you're special to us
no no so and you were echo right well I
started as weapons guy okay yep so I
went to the q courses weapons I had
later re class as an echo is God and
then a third phase which is you know big
field exercise doing like your FIDs and
your UW and all that the
the the traditional special-forces tasks
so but yeah I I failed out of first face
and it was i failed first I failed
survival in first phase now I was an SF
baby keep in mind and and the senior
guys did not dig that they were privates
going through the q course there was
some animosity there bro they they
weren't digging that [ __ ] at all they
were like keepers of the crypt you know
survival was cool and I don't think they
run it the same way anymore I'm not even
sure they do it all but back then it was
six days you got no food they send you
they they drop you off an area of like
you or E National Forest and they give
you one ration for those six days and
it's either a live chicken or a live
rabbit now they teach you prior to I you
know you get you learn all field craft
stuff and everything you know how to
make fire how to kill stuff all this
stuff and then within those six days you
have you have a list of 22 things you
have to accomplish and a lot of them are
easy you know you got to build this
massive signal you got to build a
shelter you got to keep a fire going
24/7 you got to find water you got a
filter water you know just a lot of
things but I'm gonna try to cut this one
just a little short but I was I was
thriving and surviving I was kicking ass
because I did a lot of it as a kid
running around the woods fishing and
stuff like that so I was crushing it and
I found a pond that was within the
confines of my blood because they they
told you you know here is where you are
you could only move within this amount
this radius you know you can't go I
forget what it was but within the
confines of my boundary I found a little
pond it was right on the edge of it well
well there's pond
people fish where people fish people
throw trash and sure [ __ ] up on a little
camping spot and and I found trash and I
was licking like yodel wrappers and
stuff I found a little remnants of
chocolate and I found fishing line in
the tree in the trees because guys were
cast and we
I climb these trees and pull and
meticulously pulled out all these these
nice long strings of good fishing line
bobber hooks all this stuff and as I'm
looking around this campsite I see a
beer can sitting up on a log and I go
over I feel it and I go oh man there's a
beard there's something in here smelling
it so I cut the top over me with my
knife and sure enough you know it's like
two-thirds full you know beer and
there's bugs on it and I chugalug this
thing then I go fishing and I catch a
string or load of these massive
bluegills a stringer load I mean like
sustenance like but like I'm gonna get
full today
now when you when I went back to my
campsite
you know priorities where it started
over again get your fire going make sure
you know everything's squared away
because the tax or the instructors come
by every night to check on you make sure
you're alive and they read your log
because you're a log what you did during
the day and he's looking at my string of
fish and I got some smoke and you know
and he's like what in the hell I said
yeah I got you know all these blubber
bun and and I was child I found that
worms are when you're hungry they are
good and if you cook them there's
they're just food yeah they're just at
this food you know you cook them in a
little bit of water and you're kidding
your canteen cup
there's nothing freaking gross about him
and they are good so I was I was chowing
down not only on the worms but all this
fish and I was smoking it I hadn't
killed my chicken yet this is like day
three
chickens just walking I got him tied up
with a little piece of the gun at 5:50
quarters block man yeah he's like a big
my buddy
but that was part of the task so I had
to kill him eventually because that was
wrong on the checklist but I was saving
him for a rainy day
but the instructors reading my log and
he goes what's this here about a beer
and I go oh yeah yeah I found it and
this chicken [ __ ] [ __ ] pulls out
his wallet and pulls out a card and he
goes you have the right to remain silent
anything you say can you read me my
rights bro because you know why because
was drinking beer on duty dude this is
survival bro he was pissed that I was
surviving so that was and you were a
private right and it was a private so
that was the 10 points so you have it
there was this point system and I
already lost a bunch of points just
doing dumbass [ __ ] but that was my last
10 points I had to go I had to read they
allowed me to recycle because I I act
and this is that last thing you do and
in first first place sucks man it sucks
it sucks I remember you not got
patrolling being so cold and sleep
deprived deprived that I piss myself you
know it on like 33% security I mean and
so now I have to do this all over again
Oh first face it but that that was the
story of my life in the military and
that's the kind of thing though like you
were saying earlier that's the kind of
thing that gets people's heads oh right
because they don't you know they they
say yeah yeah I'm not doing all the skin
I made it this far now you're gonna tell
me to do all of ya that's not you guys
are stupid I don't want to be a part of
this camp of people that are [ __ ]
now that's not happening yeah they ain't
in your head for [ __ ] was very easy when
I left camp McCall and went back to Fort
Bragg and got hot
you know chow hall food and me and a
shower to go yeah this is this is
comfort here this is where I want to
stay you know you there's that point
where you you could you could accept you
know being mediocre where I could see it
and I was like you know no [ __ ] way
man I want that so bad
I want that green beret so bad I really
want that and they're giving me the
opportunity because they didn't have to
they could have said [ __ ] you
they're giving it to me hell yeah [ __ ]
man I just same thing with combat dive
school and when when did you go to
combat dive school was that well we're
already at a group yeah so I was in
first group well before we get there so
what was the rest of you know the
cuecore yeah the rest of the queue
course no did you have to do language
back then no back there no language we
did that when we got
got it yep so the rest of it just kind
of it it sucked because you because you
needed some experience you needed to
know how to write in operations order
and you need to know what you know
five-point contingency plan was and pace
report and oke Oke
and all those acronyms you know as a
private you don't have any of that you
guys who were coming and they've had you
know 82nd back 82nd airborne background
or Rangers I mean they're actually
squared away squad beaters yes the night
of a minimum they knew the Ranger
handbook you know by heart inside out I
knew none of that [ __ ] and none of it
none of it so thankfully there was a
staff sergeants and he sevens who saw me
and went there's something about you and
they kind of took on the
responsibilities mentor and I jumped on
it I jump on out with those guys you
know these guys were like first Ranger
Battalion
you know 82nd airborne a were hardened
infantry dudes for like six years
already and they knew all that [ __ ] all
of it because with it there was no way
without them there's no way I would have
made it no freakin way you just don't
have you don't have the freakin sense
and you got to know there comes a time
when you're going through training like
that where you got to know you know what
Who am I gonna align myself with who is
it that I'm gonna align myself with any
end
I can't look like a [ __ ] I got to
make sure that I'm never late light out
of uniform because otherwise he's squirt
away soldiers they're not gonna want me
to hang out with him if I'm just some
piece of [ __ ] who's literally strap
hanging on to them I want them to want
me to hang out with them so I made that
happen by you know being uh work ethic
you know of a volunteer for the [ __ ]
duties out in the field that kind of
Fisher because nobody wants to volunteer
you know when you're out patrolling
nobody wants to volunteer when you're
patrolling it somebody says hey we need
to build this or go on this
reconnaissance
but I could stay here in a patrol base
so I volunteered for every one of those
things but you know you I learned a lot
on those two because I'm with some
infantry badass dude some grunt and you
know he's teaching me along the way just
OJT so I mean I made it by the skin of
my teeth
I would say you know that training I did
not graduate as an undergraduate or
anything like that but you know down the
road I did I did very well at different
schools but uh well it's like that thing
where you know you get the kids in
school that got held back a year right
you know and they do a lot better I mean
obviously you know when you're that
young and I was the same way unless when
I was 18 and it's just like I look back
now I'm like well I'm the same thing
like okay I'm glad I made it there
because there was guys that were a
little older and you just think man they
had a they just knew more they were
physically more developed than I was and
you know you just just try and hang on
man yeah hang on
yeah let me just snap link to you man
that's another thing is in basic SEAL
training there's you don't learn you
basically don't learn anything right it
just six months of just suck just yep
just this is just gonna suck you don't
really you don't go on I mean like I
said you don't go on patrol you go on
some patrols you know you go through the
land warfare phase which is six weeks
and you gonna you know you've gone long
humps and you do these little missions
but it's not it's it's not anything it's
you don't you're not actually learning
to anything you're just having to suck
it up it's a good way to trim the fat
though the only have really wants to be
here because SF what now they have you
know like a selection and assessment
process back then it was called preface
so just a couple weeks of just beat down
yeah that's it was PT four times a day
you know three hours of sleep a night
for a cup and there was no rhyme or
reason to it there was nothing there was
nada
I don't think there was a single piece
of hip-pocket training you know it was
just formation run push ups sit ups get
up get down roll over go
clean this clean that pick up those
pinecones Petey again it just yeah just
a beat-down but it was a good way to
trim the fat first guys are like [ __ ]
this man so you graduate you get through
and then where did where did you go for
I went to first group out of Fort Lewis
Washington yeah Arctic jungle yep yeah
we used to go up there and trade right
it's frickin awesome already junk really
yeah south radio training area you know
that's like a jungle and if Bigfoot
exists that's where he lives understand
thanks for heatless man holy crap hey so
you check-in so what would you do when
you check didn't you go to an 18 right
out of the out right right out of the
gate I went right to an 18 and man
talk about being intimidated all over
again I'm going with private on this
team you know team sergeants Vietnam vet
I mean the team commander was badass
there were two other there was another
Vietnam vet and every one of these dudes
from Ranger Battalion not even 82nd they
were all Rangers all and then me me no
asset I have nothing to offer
what am I have a cherry weapons dude on
a freakin a-team just a cherry who could
PT his ass home yeah that was that you
know I get peachy my ass off and I could
volunteer for all the [ __ ] duties and
make sure that every you know all my kid
is squared away and and that I'm gonna
I'm gonna you know and then I'm gonna
stay out of trouble so you've been
wandering army for what like two years
at this point oh yeah yeah yeah if that
year and a half a year and a half and
the other guys been in the Army for ten
years all right twelve yes six year nine
years and you're the only guy that's it
yeah yeah it was
and there Nam vets yes right I was the
new guy so many times even when I went
to second 85 or something like that
no before this is 84 when I went to 484
I got there and 84 beginning 85 the cool
thing too is um I got opportunity just
like that boom boom boom
do you want to go to the school that's
goes like hell yeah send me you know if
you if you're asking me that yet the
answer is yes I want to do all of the
things yeah all I don't want to just
ride it out and accept mediocrity you
know and be just be another dude I don't
want to be top on that totem pole okay
so my butt talents are major was famous
a Vietnam vet like Donald J Taylor but
highly decorated he saw me one morning
and I was running through the battalion
area and he goes private mad Khmer and
he looked a member jackieo Jack Palance
the actor you know he's kind of like
Jack O'Lantern you know I had that scowl
on his face I go yes sir major why were
snapped parade rest because I'm having a
surprise inspection at the barracks this
morning and I want you to beat my record
or my room is [ __ ] up
yeah it's jack it's Jack well the thing
is like that morning I got a call from
greyhound cuz I shipped all my stuff
greyhound because back then you know it
was like $15 anywhere in the country so
I had a ship from Fort Bragg to Fort
Louis my all my duffel bags and my team
started to take go pick your [ __ ] up a
greyhound I went and God brought it to
back to my room dumped it all over the
freaking room and then right after
accountability formation at like 0-9 or
whatever that's when he grabbed me and
I'm going oh my god I go Roger that
Center major when you want to start he
goes you got something to write on
something to write with
let's start right now my room we did
three four we lived in the old I was
those World War two barracks and World
War Two the white freaking the Rays they
got the minute
crawlspace underneath and I swear my
mind was the last room to get inspected
last last building last room and he's
been ransacking [ __ ] I mean dump and
drawers and knocking over beds you know
there was something to skew with some
reason he was just ransacking and look
for clues or booty you know look for
paraphernalia he got to mind open that
door and there's [ __ ] everywhere and he
goes who the [ __ ] this and he looks at
the nametag and the door and he looks at
me and he kind of smiles and he opens I
should you this sucks
clever no wit you know wit I like I
appreciate wit when guys have wit and
this is how witty those dudes are he
opened up the first door let it hit the
floor BAM and [ __ ] just freaking jumps
out of it and in that drawer I had three
seven six two rounds couldn't have ammo
in the barracks and I had $200 in cash
she couldn't have that a lot of cash in
the barracks either and he picks up the
money and he picks up the bullets and he
walks over to me and he looks at the
money goes is this a bribe for whoever
finds these any jobs and he [ __ ] just
hey pay maker right to the breadbasket
laughs or I double over but that
wall-to-wall counseling back then I
would much rather have that than an
article 15 for sure I mean but my [ __ ]
was wrapped so tight after that I mean I
never ever never [ __ ] up again I mean
I thought I was screwing away before
that no I was I was on it like a bonnet
you know I was talking about this the
other day like the it sounds like you're
going through the same thing one thing
that was awesome for me when I joined
the Navy is what I wanted to do when I
were out I really just wanted to do is
just like a be a good seal yeah and like
whatever I could do to try and be a good
seal and when that's your goal man it's
like your whole life is pretty good
because like we are trying to stay in
shape you're trying to get have your
gear ready you're trying to be squared
away like that's what you're trying to
be a good teammate you're trying to
volunteer for stuff it's such a it's it
it's you know when you hear there's a
lot of
people are running around that now
myself including included saying like
hey you gotta have a mission you got to
be you know driving course of yeah the
meaning is found in responsibility
Jordan Peterson right right right
well for me it's like Oh guess how lucky
I was
I was a total knucklehead kid and and I
had an aim my aim was this broad thing
of like hey I'm gonna try and be a good
seal right like if that's what you're
trying to do man it just it puts you on
a path right you know put you on a good
path yep and it sounds like pretty
similar for you you're getting on a good
path hey I want to be a good Special
Forces soldier and when you screw
something up you tighten up even more
yep and and and you know and they were
always giving me opportunity to improve
myself and I never let one of those
opportunities pass I mean do you want to
get like combat dive schools a hell yeah
that's another one I failed by the way
how do you fail to combat down well
here's the thing I think nothing about
nothing no I I had no idea what that sky
I thought I was going to like die for
conch shells in Key West or something no
idea none no pre scuba which is a
prerequisite okay just that hey bat Mac
private Mac you're fit were you a water
guy at all yeah yeah yeah I'm strong in
the water and I was on a water team
scout swim team okay with infer and
first group so a lot of surface swimming
you know just dragging a rock surface
swim I went to combat dive school and
once again you know everybody's
screaming at you your PT until you
freakin you know I I got an umbilical
hernia but water is the great equalizer
it is indeed there is no doubt about it
and so when when they started having us
doing car like the PT thing I was like
alright this sucks this sucks but then
you know you have a couple classes and
then right to the pool and everybody
screaming at you and you're trying to
get your gear and as fast as possible
and you know you got these twin ATS on
your back and the second stage is
stuffed into your BC and you're not
breathing and stuff it's just all wait
20 pound
belt mount the gunnel prepared out of
the water and in the water and then to
terror you know with the crossovers so
the crossover thing to me blew my mind
talk about you know humility how to make
somebody humble you know how to suck the
freaking life right out of you it's
explained crossover so it this
particular pool you know it was a what's
it what's an Olympic swimming pool at
the with 50 by 25 yeah it's pretty wide
it's pretty yeah it's probably 50 by 20
yeah so it's like 25 and this pool is
nice and it was 18 feet to Dean so
you've got guys on each side of the
gunnel too so on each side of the pool
so and your your your chest to back
you're just stacked up and you got a
mask on and you got your buoyancy
compensator you got your twin 80s you
got a 20 pound weight belt you got air
in those tanks you're just not breathing
it that regulators stuffed in your BC
the instructor yell out prepare to cross
over cross over so one you both sides go
underwater and the objective is to make
it to the other side one side goes
shallow one side goes deep and you come
up and you get a few puffs before they
say prepare to cross over cross over it
ain't enough time especially if you had
no pre scuba you had you haven't
experienced this and then you do it
again and again and again and people
start dropping like flies and what the
when the dropping is it quitting yeah
sometime with me for example it wasn't
necessarily I didn't say I quit I refuse
to get off the wall because it was a
shock because I already had a shallow
water blackout so I already had a
shallow water blackout they in with the
shallow water blackout it's basically
you once again the human body is cool
because you won't let you drowned unless
you want to drown unless you inhale
water you're you're gonna pass out
before that happens
so when you hold your breath long enough
you just pass out and there's school at
this [ __ ] they know cuz it happens to
people all times so they go down they
freak and bring you up and usually as
soon as you come back up and they slap
you on the surface you're you revived
you're coming out of it and then then it
takes your while you know you're like
holy [ __ ] that was scary and then they
ask you once you provide to give you
some oxygen do you want to get back in
the water the answer from you is yes I
do and then I had another one and the
next day during cross overs it was I had
that other one they said you want to get
back in the water yes I do
another cross over and I couldn't get
off the wall and the rule was they tell
you three times and you're out get up
the wall mister and there they want you
to succeed they want it they want you to
there's like Tom telling you that's the
first one I'm gonna give you another one
mister get off my wall because it's not
get off ma get off my wall get off my
wall you know they want they want you to
want this yes you're you're a you're a
fellow SF right right yeah they want you
to want this so and super super
professional cadre so they gave me the
third one and it didn't happen
I was froze that I was stuck to it but
that's another one that I avenged I went
back
I've got pre scuba and I went out I
[ __ ] killed that school not only did
I kill it but I was volunteering for
[ __ ] for instance I had a buddy who
during [ __ ] bottom search so you that
was that's some scary [ __ ] you know [ __ ]
bottom search cuz your back is on the
frickin deck man you feel your your
2080s in the in the muck in that and and
and your you're basically wandering with
your hand the bottom of this boat this
ship and you could feel that ship rising
and sinking just a little bit just a
little bit just those couple inches but
what happened to my buddy of mine is
there was a type of cylinder 8 type of
jellyfish that was on the ship itself
and when he was washing basically
Washington the ship they went down his
blouse into his shorts and he got a
freaking he got like stung by jellyfish
all the way from his chest always
ballsack
so it was medical emergency up I'm sure
this is a funny thing when we got him on
shore he's going he's burning up you
know it's jellyfish and so here's a
grown man and this is one time where you
don't question this [ __ ] where a grown
man is ripping his clothes open he's
going piss on my face my dick you know
we're all shrunk up because we're frozen
and then we got our dicks in our hands
were like five dudes it's not one guy
well he had a really bad reaction and he
started throwing up and he failed the
next day's subsurface swim 1,500
subsurface swim but he get to make it up
on a Saturday and we had that Saturday
off and they asked for volunteers
somebody got to be a swim buddy somebody
got to be a swim buddy and I figured and
volunteered and this guy was bad he was
way more badass than I was so I was a
little nervous because I didn't want to
slow him down and we we mounted the gun
and went and boom he or you know got the
surface got his bearings he gave me a
freaking you know that go down signal
and we start Finan and I am struggling
to keep up with everything I'm honest
Heather you know I'm like oh he can't
feel I can't I have to keep up with this
dude and he is an absolute cyborg and
that was the hardest I ever worked in my
life because now I'm not working for me
I'm working for somebody else and I
can't let this dude down you know oh my
god but he crushed it he crushed it yeah
what was the time space between you
failing dives going and going back one
here okay so it is so this is like I
don't know six months that was - yeah
six months one year was for selection
were you guys were you guys uh we got
going on deployments at this time yes
okay
yeah and where were you guys deploying
to for us at first group it was
Southeast Asia Thailand Malaysia those
kind of things yes and it's cold war
right yep cold war fid stuff peacetime
army
Jew did you have to learn a language at
this point yeah I was pretty good at
Thai I didn't do it was a condensed
course like a three month huh you know
so you learn all the survival skills and
all that but yeah and then then where
did you go when you how long did you
stay there for how long just in that
first group well uh like three and a
half years and then I got recruited by
some dude I got really he had a list of
ten of ten ten names on this on this
sheet in this folder and company so our
majors told us who he had to go to this
meeting and he's some dude he's civilian
clothes and he's got long hair uh and
he's the it's so vague what he's
explaining to us he goes yeah it's a
cold war job and it's in Europe it's
I've kind of felt like Will Smith I'm
men in black when he's go now what do we
do it here again well we're looking for
an embarrassed or the best oh but you
know that kind of [ __ ] I had no idea but
I knew it was something bigger than what
I was doing currently so once again
opportunity not afraid jumped on that
[ __ ] man and what we were doing with
that is how we were like building
networks for double agents working in
Berlin so before that went and got
German language as well but that was a
cool job because it was some real
cloak-and-dagger [ __ ] you know there's
some books written about it now that are
pretty cool did you go over there like
undercover no that one no okay was
different times when I did we had it
like that it was softcover and you had
to have for that one you have to have
cover fraction come for status you know
why you here in this country besides you
know I'm just some military nug right
because we had you know track suits
leather jackets mullets you know you
know all that freaking looking like
Eastern Eurotrash body odor smoking
cigarettes that gig for I did that for
about a year and a half and then I I got
recruited by some other dude he came and
he was looking he had one name on his
list it was mine
well because I had there was certain
thing
they were looking for him it was a very
the skillset was very particular he had
to be good at the language he had to be
good at like driving and there was
certain different motor skills you know
all his tests anyway I met the quota I
met the data that he was looking for and
now this guy's in uniform but he's a SF
guy and I said there's another SF job
here he goes yeah man
he was were spying on the Soviet Army in
Soviet East Germany I say get the [ __ ]
out of here
I said never heard of this just now
there's only seven slots 7sf slots seven
so I jumped on that one so that was more
schools I had to go to whippet Warsaw
Pact ID school in England more driving
schools get my language because now I'm
working in East Germany their second
language ain't English if you know what
I'm talking about I mean you know and I
did that for about two years that was
cool and once again you're going over
there as an army dude on this one I was
over as an army dude the cover for
action cover status on that one is a we
were liaison to the Soviet Army they all
knew what the hell we were doing that it
was paper-thin man the cover was
paper-thin and it was all cat mouse they
knew it they issued well they're doing
it back to us ah they were doing it back
to us in West Germany we were way more
aggressive I think at the time 95
percent of the intelligence on the
Soviet Army was coming from those units
so in East Germany the US was doing it
the French and the Brits and we would
all rotate sectors and it was scary it
was scary gig because they were the
Soviets reserved the right to to kill
you
they issued you maps and on these maps
they had to these yellow mark yellow
areas and they were called PRA
permanently restricted areas and you
couldn't go in this those areas well
that's where all the good [ __ ] was you
know all the freaking KGB comes and all
the nuke stuff so we probe those things
and it was
it was so the cover was paper-thin how
we were doing stuff was you know could
you had you were going over with two
guys one of the guys was at SF dude the
other was a an officer who was a Russian
FeO or something like that or Intel we
know no tactical skills man whatsoever I
mean I remember sitting down and you say
you'd go over with then we go from from
West Berlin to India Germany into East
Germany okay
across the glienicke Broca and we had a
Soviet credentials and and we would go
to the like the consulate or was
something like that and deliver mail so
that was how we got in and we did it all
the time it was you know several times a
week yeah and then when as soon as you
cross the bridge and you deliver your
mail you were you stayed in country now
for about three days and you did your
mission and you had you know a list of
tasks subject yes you had you had your
essential tasks lists and what will be
like a task that you oh one of them
would be there is because satellite
footage still existed so what's going on
in Cutlass there's a big military
exercise what we need is just pictures
of the vehicles and unit affiliation see
who's there you know filiation
satellites can't get you an affiliation
but you know we can get up close develop
pictures of all the vehicles and the
bins and get you an affiliation another
one might have been railways were a big
one railways you know what's coming in
from to check side polish side what is
coming in to Falkenburg into the Rick
train station and it all actually was
tarped but we we were experts in
topology too we can read the piece of
acquit equipment under petard even a
variant bro I'm talking like the beater
ATP be too irregular to a beater 70 you
know yeah we even know the variance
under tarp it was
it was good [ __ ] that was a fun ass
freakin job scary as hell
scary so because we're so people thing
here's the other job we had because I
imagine you I mean you're carrying a
camera with you you can telephoto little
clandestine K no no no we're travelling
in a Mercedes Galindo Bhagat because if
we're not undercover traveling because
we're a liaison to sidearm right so
we're in a Oney green Mercedes GLE end
of August are like a Mercedes G but it's
souped-up and it's got it was very very
high speed [ __ ] in a low speed world you
know we had a dashboard with toggle
switches where you could control for
instance as soon as you went over the
bridge it was an SOP turn off the switch
number one cuz I killed the horn because
you don't to have a horn
ad there was like a warn switch we
another one you turn off the brake
lights no the of the license plate
illuminator okay yep but you had a brake
light this disabler you had even
disabled one side so from a distance you
look like a motorcycle you know all that
stuff and then so it was a two seater in
the back was a big sheet at the phone
with holes cut and each hole filled a
nikon lens and each lens was attached to
an f1 body bro every freakin one of them
yeah so you just reach back boom 500
mirror HP HP HP each gate yep just went
to town and then we had a video cameras
mounted up like basically where the
visors are and with the remote on the
dash so pretty it was a high speed [ __ ]
in a low speed world for sure yeah I was
falling yeah you know man oh when
especially if you got a big hit because
it was competition with the other tour
guides we have called tour tour guides
so you know who could get the biggest
hit like I got I got a si 24 nuke best
say 24 news in the town was it called B
turrets and we heard that it might be
coming in and you know so we hung out
and I was uh I was with a squared-away
officer at the time too he was um he had
been to Ranger School
wasn't arranged but he'd been to Ranger
School and he was he got a scholarship
West Point scholarship for football so
he's a fit due to him
so I was with this dude I was fired up
and we were going after this SSA 24 and
we ended up it's a long story I'm just
gonna cut it short
we were hide behind a hay bale the
landowner came out he smashes the front
of our vehicle because we're not
trespassing we explain this is I mean
you're communist bro you know the [ __ ]
this is Soviet land but uh he gets me he
apologizes invites us to his house his
house is right on the tracks we parked
the vehicle in the backyard and orient
the cameras check out the orientation
and everything have a camera with us at
the ready because they don't know what
we're doing we're just [ __ ] off in
his field
you know his Americans they serve his
tea and coffee train comes we get the
whole video footage we got all the
stills we got all the freaking numbers
on it and we're sitting in this dude's
backyard yeah so that was a big that was
a big hit but yeah that was a fun job
because I got chased by all kind of [ __ ]
like T 80s a SS 21 oh and their thing
about Soviet kids are so much of it it's
so big you know I mean it's a massive
like there was this one called two
triples Arpita between triple stripes 3
pts PTF yeah it's like a it's a tract
pontoon that takes tanks across the
river gotta you know it's just it's
massive it's like the brontosaurus over
the of the KITT world we have nothing
that big you know and that moves that
fast and then there are BMP ones are
like the velociraptors of the kid world
you know they're just I mean it's not
it's all in a horrible state of repair
yeah but if you got a shitload of it
something's gonna work
oh that's cool that you were doing real
stuff yeah in the eighties yeah most of
the guys like that time we're doing it
the other yeah I was you know what I was
so fortunate I never had one of the
things I'm careful as I always I always
make sure I tell people that was very
fortunate I was very lucky that I had
the best mentors and I never ever rest
on my laurels you know I know the world
spoke back there knows a badass I'm a
badass tomorrow I don't need the rest of
my laurels because I hate those guys
yeah I know this is what I did yesterday
and and I don't reflect upon it a lot
but it's interesting yeah it's
interesting it's it had inter it was an
interesting career yeah and like as I
read some of the stuff that you don't I
kind of pieced together not just what's
like out there but you know I kind of
pieced together what I know about you
know so I had a little bit more in depth
I can fill in some holes yeah and that's
what got me thinking about you know when
I was opened up talking about like
soldier skills oh right I just think
about all the different things that you
did and how the variety my career and I
know like when you I mean I know you
went to some kind of camera school you
would have some identification all
didn't feel developing yes all that
stuff and I'm like oh yeah he did all
that and then he did scuba and then he
you know like everything that you've
done that's why I was asking about
languages like now you got Thai you got
your you got like you know it's skills
yeah yeah and there's tongue and I'm
scratching the surface yeah exactly so
lucky you know I was because it's not
that I'm I was you know I'm not like
some stellar super soldier I was very
lucky and I always made sure that when
opportunity knocked and it answered the
door and that man that paid off big-time
and then if I failed something I
wouldn't say yeah [ __ ] it man anything
for me I'm like no I gotta age that [ __ ]
cuz I won't be defeated that defeated me
no there's no way I'm going back and
kicking that ass
damn so what was next what's the next
one some because I was there through
reunification that had to be Korea yeah
that was cool that was cool [ __ ] so I
was there through reunification so you
know the wall came down 89 reunification
91 yes so I was there during that whole
thing but now my job is drying up and
I'm having a train the Bundys knowledge
Dean's it's like a German FBI I'm pretty
sure I got that right it's been a long
time since I access that database but um
so I have to train them and you know
we're handing over that job because they
just have to see the withdrawal now and
all that I don't want any part of that
so the next step was going to you know
try to get my foot in the door and use
the sock and so I went I got a slot to
go to selection hmm Dave freaking one I
break my ankle
how'd you break your ankle so on the
first day there's a.m. so no more
yelling and screaming yeah there's no
more that you know you're just thinking
it starts with some a chalkboard and
you're making sure you're not late late
out of uniform and you're getting food
too
it's just now it's it's all big-boy
rules you know it's a totally different
game it's a totally different tests
totally completely different you know it
because it tests resolve and whether or
not you have heart and if you're capable
of deductive reasoning and if you are
resolute and if you have yeah besides
deductive deductive reasoning there's
another term I'll think of it here a
second but um so day one there's a I
won't disclose too much of it just
because I don't want to ruin it for
people who may go in the future but
there's a physical movement you know
it's a movement and it's that night with
a rock on it's nothing hard and I think
it's they're kind of as a like a litmus
test you know maybe to help the troll
yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah and you're on your own you're doing
this thing on your own but it's at night
now you're not but you know you're on
dirt roads because you don't know it
they haven't given you any training yet
so you're on dirt roads and there's
people periodically to guide you along
the way and you have even have a
flashlight so it's nothing you know it's
nothing crazy it is just there to trim
the fat and it does a good job at it
because it'll tell whether or not you're
there for the right reasons that'll
that'll tell the Kadri but I'm coming
down a hill and whenever you have the
opportunity you know you double-time
down hills just to make up time and I
roll an ankle and I roll it so bad that
I hear a crack and I knew it was the
ankle you know the the sprain cracking
but I felt bone in my shin too and man
you know it's the worst feeling you know
when for those of us who have had sprain
it's a war it's a horrible feeling and a
sprain is worse than a break I swear to
god it's worse money there's no doubt
about it
I've done so many of them I've poured so
much [ __ ] in my body that uh man I'd
rather be broken then torn
well the big difference is when you
break a bone you put it you you put it
back together you put a cast on it
it heals up it's actually stronger than
it was right you tear a ligament yep
that thing is never this thing ever yeah
if it even heals yep
so you hammer the [ __ ] out of your ankle
yeah I and I make it through this first
movement and I think just I just make
the time I don't know what the time is
and then I end up walking on it for
another week and a half I'm going over
these mountains in West Virginia but
there came a point where I where I say
you know what this is a big boys game
and they know I'm hurt because I went to
see a doc the next day and my ankles you
know like a football and they gave me
some whatever some Ranger candy some
gamma buffered aspirin or something like
that and they gave me an ace wrap that's
it but they knew I'm jacked up and I
thought you know what these guys they
they're gonna think Everts hearted
they're gonna think I'm stupid
then I'm you know that up so I I made it
I made it I was I was making no ground I
was getting weaker
by the day so I sat by a dirt road
waited for a Kadri car to come and I
said hey I am I am volunteering
volunteering voluntarily it was a hard
pill to swallow but the thing is I had
to do that and the guy said hey as long
as you're not cheating yourself I said
nope I am NOT and they invited me to
come back well cuz they knew that I was
jacked up you know if I volunteer if I
wasn't jacked up there's no way you quit
something like that there's no way but
they knew that I was jacked up cuz I
went I actually went and saw them the
doc and I said hey can you give me
something for this and he was like what
what if you what if you just don't make
the times would they said are you failed
your out well I had one of those too is
I didn't get to that point yet I didn't
get to the stress phase of this course
you know so it was just all the training
that train but the I forget what it's
called but like the Train yeah the
training phase in our caring face it
wasn't the graded portion yet so there
was no there was no maximum time record
taken whatever out and I felt that I was
getting weaker weaker weaker every day
um so yeah they invited me to come back
and I took every bit of a year what I
did to is I made a huge gamble I was in
Germany and a volunteer to go to Swick
Special Warfare Center and to me an
instructor and four-year commitment I
volunteered to go to that to get me to
Fort Bragg to get me closer
uh-huh and did you also figure like if
I'm there and I'm all I'm doing his
teaching I can get in good shape right
sovereignity yeah yep
but if I didn't make selection I would
have been stuck in swiffer Forster so I
knew it was a gamble but I said it's
gonna get me there and it's gonna get me
strong I'm not gonna have to go anywhere
I'm not gonna you know like yeah it's
it's very light duty and I worked out
like a man possessed I took it I had a
new kind of a perspective and a new
strategy with the training I went very
low impact
so I did a lot of basically like anise
in the tiny sprocket a lot of
stair-climbing stuff like that a lot of
like 40 repetition squats that kind of
thing without a taste of it now what are
we worried about like being able the
hump though yeah yeah well I did that I
humped but I didn't do a lot of it I
didn't do a lot of breakdown what I did
is I found am there was this massive
helo pad at Fort Bragg right by where I
was working so it's an elevated chunk of
ground and it's elevated you know on all
sides at an angle and I would do laps
around that because now I'm walking on a
on a traverse on an angle so I got all
that friction you know and working my
ankles and I would you laughs it was
probably 400 yards around and I would
every day I'd go over there and I would
do lap after lap after lap and turn
around lap after lap after lap after lap
and turn around do the same thing and
till my feet burnt because I wanted
strong ankles and I wanted a tough tough
tough feat because I already had some
blisters when I went the first time that
second time I didn't have a [ __ ]
blister I had a hot spot on the last
exercise I had one hot spot yeah but I
crushed it I crushed it next time every
night I destroyed it I mean I had some
bad days but when I went back man I I'm
freakin I really I tore into it so what
years what years this now that you might
have you come back and you may 91 92
when I went back to yep 92 so so I'm
thinking Gulf War yes it all just
finished now I was still doing the
Soviet stuff when people were doing the
Gulf War huh yeah
was that driving you crazy yeah because
I was doing stuff yeah I was working you
know and it yeah I was happy I was in
boot camp torn I was just after boot
camp during the first Gulf War yeah
and they I remember watching the news
and they said they were expecting us
40,000 casualties in the first 48 hours
or something like that
and I was like oh it's so hard it's so
hard it's gonna be so long they're gonna
I'm gonna get fast-tracked they're gonna
put me in a freaking door gunner like
now
yeah Oh like you're gonna make it you
replace and that's what's gonna happen
so you get done and and so now you're uh
you're there and everything's kind of
leveled up your training freakin just
like all the yeah well you know after
selection I had to go through six months
of OTC and you're on the bubble during
that time I mean that's six months and
there's no break in that six months I
mean and you're on the freakin bubble
bro man that I love it the way they
reserve the right to fire your stinking
ass at any freaking second for anything
and that that went my whole I was I was
at the unit for 13 years and I mean
there were stellar dudes you know ten
years in whoo that little mistake oh but
but you want to work in a place like
that you know you want to you want to be
a part of that where dude and I remember
there were guys who were great dudes who
would have like I had this one friend
who had a nd he was by himself and he
went and turned himself in and was at it
he's gone yeah but with Andy's there
were certain things that you were they
sent you packing for a year and you were
you were able to get a relook certain
negligent discharge yeah oops yeah yeah
yeah yeah and they they didn't happen
often but when you're constantly around
guns you're constantly doing [ __ ] all
you need is a momentary lapse of reason
and that's it we are human beings we are
capable of momentary lapse of reason and
they they happen to the best dudes I
know man the best dudes I knew so you ad
yeah nd this is yes yes the verbage like
I don't know but decade and a half ago
there are no accidents it's negligent I
don't know there's something there's
some things that came from my eres what
I never thought I never thought about
half a yeah yeah yeah cuz I I've been on
the range enough where I've seen where
I've know that [ __ ] actually does happen
I mean I've got some great stories that
are actual a DS yeah yeah yeah like
around the cooking off not
like a a guy dropping his backpack and
he's got it like an ALS holster on car
key goes into the holster and fulcrums
up boom is he's dropping his backpack
Bogey's you know sure like that I've
said a bunch of things like that I've
seen guys with like in the summer time
out in the desert cut it off yeah and
they're like like I remember we were new
guys and one of the guys with me
he's shooting and all of a sudden you
know he's kind of we're done we're kind
of debrief and also [ __ ] he literally
has held up his weapon like there is a
there's another funny story what Jason
Gardner told me this story there
debriefing and this guy they're sitting
there deeper to do kill house stuff
they're debriefing and also like did the
junior officer cracks off around at the
feet of like the debrief group he like
looked at the gun and he looks at the
group and he goes he was decocking it he
had like an out-of-body experience of
explaining himself in the third person
do I gotta have Jason Gardner because my
buddy Jason who's Master Chief and he's
been on the podcast couple times but he
always tells everything in like a
monotone voice so you know goes yeah so
he cracks off around right at the feet
of our of our group and then he shaking
Leigh looks at everyone and says he was
decocking so as you're doing this one
other one of their skills are you now
picking up I mean you aren't it's been
easy I gotta figure out a place where
there's money right and there's time and
there's a mission yep let me think about
it
first up more driving I mean I've been
through seven driving courses one of
them was the Gary cynic motocross well
we had dirt bikes you know and and it's
a great mobility device but you need
training on that thing so when I was a
team sergeant out of mobility team I
said I want the best training I want
motorcross see in a supercross school
but so driving training i mean more
water stuff water water so riverine
stuff you know it was cool I just
thought about that they the dunk
training like epic my oh yeah gratin
thing yeah yep I did that uh but schools
let me think he dunker yeah yeah oh my
god they're so freakin much oh so the
devil was the big thing with the unit
you know but special specializing in
that group were you were you're like a
preacher yeah but everybody is a
preacher at some point you know when
you're an operator you're all you're a
breacher at some point you know you you
you you come on to a team as as
assistant and then you work up to a
breacher but then the amount of weapons
to you know so not just crew serve stuff
but like anti-tank and you know it's a
holy crap because there's always
something new emerging you can't just
look around and do stuff you know all
the time cuz more stuff is emerging what
are the kind of church it just went on
and on and on and on i mean it never the
wheels on the bus went round and freakin
round and the amount of hilo stuff that
we did you know and and a lot of
different environmental training so you
know when we did winter training it was
hardcore winter training well we did
desert rating hardcore desert we did
mountain it's hot you know all that
stuff and then so a lot of environmental
stuff bracket i mean eight yeah i wish i
wish i was tasked with the homework
assigned prior so I could have written
those things down because it but it's
cool because it's cool cuz I I forget
about how much shins and I've learned
mmm the amount of [ __ ] that I've
forgotten could probably you know fill
volumes and but every once in longer oh
yeah like Rebecca and I watch a TV show
I go yeah I've done that you have yeah I
trust me I've done that and you're
shooting just all stop insane yep yep
all the time and then not only that but
as cool as we were encouraged to compete
you know on national level with the
shooting stuff so and I'm not just
talking action shooting like epic but I
also did national match mm you know like
bullseye stuff yeah I competed in the ol
army small arms championship too in 2004
right before I retired so I was a teen I
and the unit sent me down there as a
like a recruiting trip and that's
competition I ever went to now they did
preface it with a you know you got to
win this thing now no freaking I tell
you that was not easy I did but it
wasn't easy task
cuz you got like 250 competitors and you
got these I am the army guys the are my
marksmanship guys who do that right they
do you got rangers snipers 82nd snipers
because when you show up to that type of
competition
you all look the same every same haircut
same uniform same m16a2 iron sights same
sidearm same ammo yeah same am
everything's the same sex that car
racing exactly just like that
so no mechanical advantage with anything
nothing and then you start this
week-long competition you know in the
first several days it's all national
match rifle at 500 yards iron sights
grandeur shooting you know 77 greenseer
match Black Hills you shoot good ammo so
you're you know you're really eight
you're able to group with these with
these with these rifles but after the
rifle portion I was sitting good I was
hot you know like out of 250 people I
was probably like 225 but when the
pistol pour she came up I crushed
everybody so was that because it
thankfully was a combined agri so I was
able to yeah I was able to whoo-hoo I
did not want to go back to you and say
yeah I came in third or something like
that you know I got beat by a p4 from
Division where will you when September
11th kicked off so I was at that time I
was a TC instructor so operator trainers
course instructor I was on the range
teaching our OTC students CQB one guy
had a
piece of equipment going down I saw I'll
go get it I'll go get it for you just
give me that and I'll go D exit for you
so I Drive back down to the main
buildings go in and the that's for the
guy from supply is watching the TV and
one of the planes had already hit and I
said what happened there he goes on some
plane hit one of the trade what a World
Trade Center towers and I go huh huh was
it actually because I looks like it's me
because at the time that's what it was
and it busts people you couldn't grasp
the gravity of how big those buildings
are you know they thought it was a
Cessna huh I completely thought it was
asthma yeah that's every time B could
those Billy's are gigantic so we're both
watching it and then I saw alive the
second one go in and we both just dude
when you when you watch that [ __ ] lot
happened now I didn't see another news
as a repeat I watched it live and I
heard the news that the announcer go
home oh boy oh oh alright
nope this is no accident you know now
holy [ __ ] so I got this piece of kit
boogie-down
range and we did an admin halt brought
everybody back into the chow hall big
TVs on it so they get kind of a update
and then brought him back to the shoot
house Iran CQB how long did it take from
there before before you got over to
Johnny it I was you know bummed out bro
you learned in Swat was an instructor
not only that but they asked me to do
another six months on top of my two-year
stay because there was a course that
they were putting together for somebody
else and they wanted me to build this
course I'm going oh my god squadrons are
already on their second to pull it bro
and yeah this is the crazy third
deployment so it's funny because when I
get over there I I remember the first
night I'm with this dude I put through
selection and OTC he's a staff sergeant
and I'm at nine and he goes oh Mack it's
so cool that I'm doing hits with you
here I said yeah bro it's night you're
in charge of me he goes huh I said how
many hits you got country 125 I said
well I got zero
oh yeah goose egg so when you went over
you went over you would tell me earlier
like you went over it's like a an ops
position or something yeah initially I
went over as a in an ops position
position with the wood and it's a funny
thing we didn't even touch on this one I
went over to work with the unit's
supports support squadrons and so I was
working with all and these guys with no
training and they're going outside of
the green zone and all that to get
resupplied they're going there make it
by app runs to get a diesel you know
going down route Cyrus yeah bro and
soft-skinned hovers you know because
weird nothing was up armored you know
and so I'm driving with them scared
scarce ever been in my life going with
Kooks to get freaking food I'm one man
security detail
I got comms hey are our m4 mags and I'm
good I'm out there flapping I'm one man
security detail for due to have zero
training they got guns and stuff but I
know that that that that stay scared the
[ __ ] out of me the amount of freaking
rounds that the support guys were taken
and I'm going go go you know because we
mobility survivability I'm like dude
first lesson it's hard to shoot a moving
target
you were not these other we're not
driving 50 miles an hour [ __ ] that as
fast as the vehicle could go change
lanes under bridges you know that kind
of stuff all that old-school [ __ ] I mean
yeah that scared the hell out of me and
then I would do a couple hits with them
yeah working squadron but when I got
back in between between those I built a
course called CSC combat skills course
it's a two-week course for dollar
support outlet and it was they loved it
for sure they freaking loved it they
were because you start with BRM basic
rifle marksmanship you know and then
movement with a rifle and then security
positions working barricades driving and
then you know react to freaking IEDs you
know all this stuff
so you ratchet contact move to from all
that stuff so we did all in just two
weeks of non-stop balls-to-the-wall
basic training combat skills training
and the fulfillment I got out of that
was ridiculous I've loved doing that so
much it was the job is hard it's
freaking sucked but you know these cooks
and law guys you know seeing them
freaking rip rounds shoot 80 floors and
stuff and then when I go back to Iraq
walking around we got a hit it's kind of
vanilla but the cool thing was to when
no matter how vanilla the freaking hit
was guys were treating it as if it were
you know HVT mmm you know high-value
target I was like hell yeah but there
was a couple of vanilla hits where I'd
go and get my cooks and say hey you guys
wanna hold on I'll hit me they're like
really icy yeah and I put him on you
know security position with a with a saw
or or mag 58 but dude third [ __ ]
combat bro yeah yeah yeah one of the
cooks even got the freaking Wow yeah I
got to let it rip yeah I had I had my
radio man my radio man from my Tactical
Operations Center right and he was the
guy that kind of ran things and one
night we were going on off it was pretty
pretty close to base you know kind of a
no-brainer and I needed it but we had a
bunch of people to coordinate with and I
said hey man you know you can you come
out with me tonight and you know just
man the radio he gets the big eyes
because you know hey let's face it I
mean even though I was saying there's no
big deal man there was guys getting
wounded oh he'll never say so
even though I thought it was no big deal
his eyes got real big and he's like he's
like yeah yes sir and so we get out and
we did by this point this was oh six we
had our armored armored Humvees and we
get on target and um you know I'm out we
got multiple targets going down and I'm
the GFC so I'm kind of conducting and
seeing what's going on and and I walk
over and he's in the Hummer and I go
over and I kind of like crack the door
open I was like hey man you want to come
out and you know like you know I'll show
you what's up what's going on
he's like um good to go right here just
chill but I'm he's a great guy it all
kinds of good work for me but you know
we do that with the with the support
people because it's they just they don't
get good training right and and so
they're normally not super comfortable
yet rolling out I had a I had a CD - who
is this giant black dude awesome guy
named Becky and yeah biggie he was he
was awesome but we took him on a couple
where we had work to do we had worked
for the CBS to do at some locations and
man you know seed heavy talking about
big he turned from biggie just a big
eyes awesome and one time we got hit we
got hit with get hit with mortars in the
camp and they blew up our big water tank
and so he was just you know he was a CB
which Seabees are known for you know
acquiring things so he went out in the
next few hours and acquired a brand new
like giant water tank we're talking you
know I don't know how many but as big as
this room that we're sitting yeah a
giant he brings back another one on a
crane him and Peters yeah it all filled
up in water and you know I said hey man
hey I go hey chief that's awesome man
really appreciate it appreciate you know
taking care of us he goes man I'll do
whatever I got to do to help you guys as
long as there ain't no more boom-boom in
the camp I saw biggie warming up with
315 on bench warming up ten reps
he wasn't playing around yeah yeah and
so so the second time when you went back
and you guys are doing these hits so now
what years that Oh fine yeah so things
like before am i right oh yeah yeah
things things escalated a lot between
o4a l5 yep I guess somewhere vote for
was starting to get gnarly right oh five
and are you guys are you guys are going
out
and targets reload I mean yeah a lot of
times like recaulk right there on the on
the spot so battlefield interrogation
all right this guy knows so-and-so let's
go friggin split the force and go check
these dudes out and then BAM police them
up a lot a lot of cool black police work
you know snatchin do is III tell people
like people who don't know you know when
you're trained and when you live in that
kind of unit killing a dude isn't very
hard snatching up a dude requires
requires a lot of freaking work you know
especially with like let's say plausible
deniability or no trace that kind of
thing so I love that kind of stuff that
was to me that was there was a lot of
fun as interesting you know snatching
dudes up out of their beds and crap like
that but it was um the op tempo was was
really high and what I appreciated was
being basically like a cherry you know
it I was a private e9 yeah you know
that's probably the only place in the in
the world in the military where you have
the opportunity to do that be an e 9
door kicker I mean I had this one night
because it was like my third night going
into Fallujah on my own little bird mmm
I was following in a team and we're you
know land and rooftops and that the
third night in a row they had me on the
planning board as task force man it was
killed you know what they were doing
they were giving me an opportunity to
make up ground because they had been
getting some and I've been left freaking
back so they were like yeah we're gonna
you know yeah yeah going in hi yeah yeah
it was cool [ __ ] but seeing all the
level at which dudes operated seeing
that cuz I was almost from like an
outside perspective you know looking
around go holy [ __ ] man this is pro this
is badass well I think the whole US
military obviously I mean this goes
without saying but the just am at the
experience I mean
I always tell people they're always a
little bit surprised but you know I
didn't shoot my weapon at the enemy for
13 years right you know in the SEAL team
13 years of and I think I locked my
locked and loaded my weapon prior to
that like three times all on this stupid
light I was kind of fired up because we
were doing security for something right
I got to lock and load my weapon I was
kind of pumped yeah yeah right yeah but
then but was until 13 years but the
amount of combat that we have had now a
US military repetition after repetition
after repetition and one thing I noticed
is like well on my first deployment
which was o3 we you know we were good at
doing you know building takedowns and
you do room clearance and we were we
were good at it
by the time I went back in oh six man
everybody was too everyone could you
know everyone could just there was no
factor it was like hey oh you want to
take down this building Cole we got this
it was it had brought everybody up to a
much better level and I always I think
about this now all the time just the
experience that we have now you know a
mission that would have seemed like a
huge deal in 1996 right you wouldn't
even know it wouldn't even crack the
bump on a radar like that was cool right
right yeah not even close
yeah it was so the amount of experience
that we've gained and and and you know
even when I watch new platoons come in
to relieve us and like occasionally I'd
be in that spot like looking at my tasks
looking at one of my platoons moving
down the street and you just seen you
got man these guys are so good I mean
everybody's moving it's like weapons
trained everywhere it's so efficient
then you see like a new troop coming in
and you look at him you go they'll clean
it up today because you can tell by his
demeanor you know my is just a body
language alone you know you you just the
silhouette you know who that guy is
oh sure little wet yeah for sure when
you uh so now it's you do you knock out
a couple deployments what what makes you
decide to
get out what makes you decide to retire
I had up some of it was and I don't mind
talking about this because it's good
lesson learned [ __ ] a lot of it was
because of domestic messiness I had
little kids at home and they had a they
weren't being brought up right I needed
to be there for them I had already long
you start to think what when you when
you lose buddies that are close to you
you start to you know reflect and you
you start to be very objective and you
exercise introspection and you go dude
man if that's me I don't really care you
know I'm just some dude but I'm gonna
leave my kids dry because they don't
have the other their other half sucks
mm-hmm you know they're their mom at the
time really sucked so I got out because
I had little kids and they needed they
needed me because they didn't have the
other half of that name the other half
sucked bad and it was a it was a because
of the problems stem from its big pharma
[ __ ] you know prescription meds it's not
a drug problem if it's you know
prescription meds that freaking big
pharma bro they've shipped pisses me off
but so I watch the deterioration of a
human being over you know a long time
big pharma engine she freaking just
sucked so but I had to I had to do it
and and you know initially I thought
this is a great idea but man it wasn't
long before I ran into just feeling
horrible about myself and missing the
hell out of it what was the time span
between you made the decision that
you're gonna retire and like how when
you retired I've made a decision the
first time I pushed to Iraq at the 22
year mark because I was nine I needed to
stay in grade for three years and
complete the Academy to keep inai on my
retired retirement ID card kind of thing
so I wanted to make sure that I retired
with that stuff so yeah I made that
decision got the Academy right before I
retired I think I did the Academy and
retire two days later and then you
retire did what was your plan when you
retired I had no plan there you go zero
check but I got a fire job offers like
yeah I got hired prior to retiring there
you go
couple months so that becomes the plan
yep and the thing is that's a little
hanging fruit I don't recommend that to
people that low hanging fruit [ __ ] man
you know working for the man [ __ ] that
and this is what I'm 505 so contracting
is still oh yeah good money yep yeah
this is before the market that want to
return to another [ __ ] yep the
reason I got out was to be there for my
kids so I didn't want to you know make a
[ __ ] ton of money and deploy get right
freakin 90 days without the big green
machine at my six for sure because that
now I lost some buddies do it
contracting stuff too and it was just
kill me bro I was killing oh my god so
it was the job that you go so which it
was basically doing what I'm doing now
ish but for a corporation it I was doing
the instruction thing and I was built
and uh
this unit called the AWG mmm asymmetric
warfare group yep if I was build a bad
you sent some people over to me and
Ramadi yeah and I was the other thing I
was doing was I built a course called
Katzie combat applications training
course and we were training big army I
recruited a couple other guys couple
guys like me retired unit guys and we
were training big army at five day
course and I loved when we first started
it we were doing training first Brigade
82nd Airborne Division 4th brigade 4th
Brigade photogate was fitted for a
little while and I love that these guys
were so badass you know that there were
ephors with two deployments for sure and
with combat wounds yeah stuff by the way
two deployments that work
13 right 13 months yes yeah
and they were so badass and their
soldier skills were you know so far
surpassed than what I had seen in like
the 90s reserve so that was once again
very fulfilling you know running these
guys hard getting really good training
and make it a focus on the fundamental
fundamentals fundamentals be an expert
at the basics you know that was that
still is my thing but that was our thing
when we were training the cat C program
expert on the basics and fundamentals so
that was fun I did that for a few years
and then I got um I got laid off what
the [ __ ] does that mean you don't know
it you have note what your career
military yeah and then you're working
for you know a company that does
government contracting [ __ ] is all
retired military you're not even
thinking job security that's not even
that's not a part of your thought
process you don't go bad at now you can
say oh hope I don't get fired tomorrow
if you don't think that you don't think
it so laid off things yeah and I didn't
even see the writing on the wall
cuz I'm dumb I'm on corporate America I
don't know any of that stuff so the
company got bought out and they started
to you know cut corners from the fat
pitch pennies all that stuff and I was
thinking oh yeah we got to do it you
know I got to cut those corners got to
pinch those pennies I wasn't thinking
about me cost money and they laid me off
with a phone call man a phone call you
know now you face to face and the
feeling cuz I was already down at that
time I was really bummed out I was um I
was in a dark dark place I was going
through depression and I was freaking
drinking on the job that I could not on
the range I would bring like a Jack and
Coke to work in a kid a big coca-cola
bottle and stuff like that I was hating
life I was miserable and that's what you
got your your I guess she's your ex-wife
now she's dragging things down yeah no
support whatsoever disconnected from
your former teammates that you spent
your entire life with
has no concept about that stuff and not
only disconnected from that but
disconnected from reality because of
like prescription meds and stuff so no
connection between the neuroreceptors
just dark space every once in a while
target of opportunity you know a moment
of clarity but now all that [ __ ] sucked
bad then getting laid off you know on
top of it was like holy [ __ ] then the
other half say no just get a job with
another company and I'm like [ __ ] that
man I want to do something else
so I called three guys who owned owned
companies all good friends of mine all
xunit guys and they all said the same
thing yep I will get you back I will get
you work if you need it but do it man do
it yourself you can you have the ability
to do this so they all gave me
permission to be my own guy the best
thing that ever could happen to me
because I was 10 years ago and I
generated my company Tmax and it just
freakin detonated as it went batshit I
mean there's absolute flows it's scary
you running your own business you know
there's absolute flows not you know like
ripped off by a promoter we'll had to go
through the sequestration 2013 all that
deficit spending [ __ ] where I had
all government contract stuff for the
year and then that like switch one out
and you are on no money none at the same
time I'm going through divorce you know
and dude that was hard that was hard but
that was good it was freaking odd it was
so good
those kind of lessons learned you know
you really grow it as a human being
based on how you how you come out of a
bad situation like that you know how how
how you for me it was making lemonade
out of lemons mm-hmm you know and trying
to rekindle my past trying to remember
who I was what I'm here for what my
purpose is and then I had to get myself
meaning you know well I needed to be
there needed to be a reason for me to
get up every freakin day a new mission
yeah every day new mich yep because
that's what especially special objects
not just military guys of a Special Op
cast they need that perp
they need that mission so without
meaning without purpose you you could
you could falter he could short-circuit
yourself you could you know start
slipping in the dark places and you were
slipping there dude I almost capitulated
I was close i I mean I was dark I was at
the bottom bottom and then I it was a it
was a it
it was glasses for years I lived in the
bonus room above my garage for five
years I lived in the bonus room above my
garage I wasn't a drunkard but I was
drinking all day so nobody knew it you
know that I was that I was medicating
nobody knew it because I would just all
day long all day long you know eleven
o'clock in the morning start and I had
no I mean I would go to work I would get
jobs and I was faking it I was faking
that you know did you saw him but I go
you know I'm all that I was just faking
the Mack show just faking it nobody knew
where I was nobody had any idea cuz I
had no I wasn't like hanging I had no
close friends or anything like that my
kids were my close friends and they were
my kind of my sanctuary I must escape
you know hanging out with them are you
still working out at that time not very
much I mean I'm getting by because
everything that I did my might might now
X thought it was because I was having an
affair you know so there is no other
explanation from you work and how other
than wanted to [ __ ] somebody you know
there's no explanation everything that I
did was because it's an affair and I had
in her mind I mean it was bad when
people wouldn't you know people when I
say yeah my ex is crazy thing oh I know
what you're talking about
oh yeah yeah I say no man I'm not
talking [ __ ] you're cut I'm talking to
legit crazy I had a girlfriend imaginary
girlfriend living in her closet for four
years her name was Skeeter I would come
home and the cops would be at my house
she had taken all the light switch
panels off and showing the cops that
there are blue washers because a bug in
the house you know stuff like that I
would come home for Ford I remember
doing this one trip for up 24th STS you
know CCT guys badass dudes for days
trading hours wiped out man I was smoked
and I was coming back from oops up by uh
Moyock you know yeah so for me it's like
a five-hour drive and i am i back in my
drive with the truck and I'm looking to
rear view mirror and all my shoes in the
driveway it's all on the driver and
she's sitting on a stool she's going
through like my tackle box you know and
all my tools it it's all just everything
she's looking for clues or something you
know that was that was just I remember
that night that was the straw that broke
the camel's back and she called the cops
at night cops came and they said hey can
you stay somewhere else I go yep
absolutely
because there been a hotel that I've
been going to mm-hmm it was just a mile
down the road next day one the cops
calls calls me and he says um can I talk
to you so I said where yeah he said I'm
at your house I Drive there he goes hey
I ran into your wife in the village
she's frigging doped out of her mind he
said brother
that he knew who I was where I came from
and stuff like that very nice guy he
goes you need to take the radical steps
and you need to get the [ __ ] outta here
I know you're in it for the kids kids
are resilient they will handle they will
be able to handle it but you need to get
the [ __ ] out
and I was go man I was broke down
because nobody at that until that nobody
I rely I felt that I was all alone in
the world that I was going through this
[ __ ] you know that nobody had any idea
the cops had seen it cuz they'd been
there many times but um that night I get
jacked up again and I'm with my sweet
son James and I'm talking to him and and
I remember telling him how old is he at
this Hayes probably and we see 13 what
would it was
seven okay and he said I said James I
don't just love you I am in love with
you and he started crying that really
meant something to him you know it
really meant something and then I
realized [ __ ] man this kid really digs
me you know really freaking Daisy
so I he fall asleep I take him to bed
and I go back up into my bonus room and
I realized that I need to make a change
now this has to happen now
so that hole that I was looking at that
I was almost capitulated to you know I'm
at the bottom of the hole it was like an
epiphany where I I'm not letting this
this [ __ ] burying me I will not be
defeated I am not buried I have been
planted you know it was it was this
moment of clarity I had I put out my
running shoes and put my my my ipod I ya
iPod out my headphones put out some
shorts and I said all right set an alarm
clock I'm gonna go for a run tomorrow no
plan just let me go clear my head got up
full of piss and vinegar put the [ __ ] on
and I ran and I'm not a ground pounder I
like the sprint I like running but I ran
for about an hour and a half just
non-stop I just kept running around town
you know got back in my driveway I'm
starving and I look at the house and I'm
going oh this is the house where dreams
gonna die I don't want to go inside so I
stay in my driveway I work out for like
another two hours just up and down I
have some dumbbells and they I pull it
bar and I just workout for like another
two hours I mean to the point of like
incapacitation but that was it that was
my that was my rebirth thinking there's
no way I'm gonna be defeated by this
there's no way and I I am not buried I
have been planted but that was the
beginning of the whole and then with the
cop coming the day before mmm it's
saying get the [ __ ] out so that day I
got the [ __ ] out grabbed your [ __ ] and
left yeah it was just 500 yards away I
found a condo because I didn't want to
be far from my kiddies yeah for sure
so it was like 500 yard
as a crow flies and just but you know I
didn't need things I needed my guns and
some tools and that kind of stuff and
packed up what I what I could and just
freaking boogied yeah and started that
arduous process of domestic messiness
and lasted for a long time with me
because I was trying to get custody to
at the time and trying to do that in
North Carolina it's like pulling
freaking teeth yeah ladies you need um
there got to a point where I was going
the cop said go see the magistrate in
magistrate I went to the magistrate
magistrate I pleaded my case magistrate
says you need to call Mobile's
[Music]
Mobile crisis management call Mobile
crisis management and they say you need
to talk to her shrink I go to the shrink
they won't talk to me they say go tell
the police so send me in a big circle
mmm so I finally talked mobile crisis
management into they said we're
voluntary they have to voluntarily
commit themselves as can you least talk
to her so they talked to her they came
out said yes paranoid and delusional no
doubt I said so what does it take she
goes there has to be basically in in the
state something horrible happen has to
happen first like let me set the house
on fire let me drown the kid that kind
of thing then okay now it's okay you got
yeah it's I said are you [ __ ]
[ __ ] me this is how it works
I said you're basically that's what
those are my words I said basically what
you're telling me is something horrible
happens have to first and they said yeah
that's exactly what I'm telling you
something horrible happen it has to
happen first
as you as you look back at this yep like
from your perspective right now because
a lot of guys that a lot of veterans got
guys that have gotten out and a lot of
guys you know they have a rough time
with it is there advice straight up when
when a guy is looking at the abyss when
a guy's thinking everything sucks when a
guy's thinking they lost their job their
wife's acting crazy whatever all these
things pile up is there advice that you
have for guys that get in that situation
what I always tell people is like you
need to find a new mission that's
exactly what I mission or I say purpose
or meaning you so and meaning could be
volunteering somewhere it could be going
to the gym you know saying it's all
semantics yeah but you have to have
purpose and meaning you have to find
those things so one other thing this is
a funny this I volunteer every day I
have five guys I train at my gym it's
grown us I do a voluntary voluntary but
they're relying on me to show up you
know so it's again they always say
thanks bro man because I'm changing
their lives these are guys I know they
work in the community the you know it's
my mechanic my up the owner of my pub
those kind of things but you know I'm
changing their lives but the other thing
I tell them is bro thank you because you
know you're getting me here you're
getting here you keeping me on my
programming and you're giving me purpose
and meaning I'm still gonna probably
freakin get some anyway because that's
who I am but you know you're keeping me
on schedule keeping me on track that
kind of thing so thank you but yeah you
got to have that you know new mission
statement purpose and meaning you got to
have those things especially guys who've
been in for a long freakin time and
sometimes it pisses me off because I'll
have guys ask for advice and they'll say
yeah I'm in a dark spot you know I'm
loving life and and kids who love me and
I want to tell them bro [ __ ] you you
know what because I had to do that [ __ ]
without that with hate with disdain and
that's your reason right there man
that's your mission you got a wife a
freak
digs the hell out of you it supports
everything you do you know that's your
queen bro
lay out the friggin carpet maker your
mission is to make her coffee cook for
her clean your house or whatever it is I
don't know make a lot of money so she's
comfortable yeah and then what was it as
your business grew like what was them
what was some things that that kind of
accelerated your business I think the
big thing is I don't you know all my
eggs aren't in one basket that's a big
one but because that business is good
but I been hit before by like
sequestration and stuff like that it
could be a mo crisis or whatever because
basically my businesses is uh you know
shooting combat marksmanship close
quarter battle those kind of things um
that works well that runs well because I
have my own brand of training
methodology and you know it can't be
replicated we're all teaching basically
the same thing it's just that how do you
deliver that you know what is your
delivery platform how do you reel it
because that's what people are buying I
mean you could teach somebody to squeeze
the trigger the same way I can but how
do you deliver that message and then you
know what words do you use and what
demonstrations can you put together and
how is this important or why so that
business goes good and then I just I
keep putting some jam and [ __ ] into the
pipeline you know when I mean I still
don't want a man when opportunity knocks
I'm like yep I'm snatch that up I'm
doing that and it's been a double-edged
sword because the last couple years I've
got really smoked so this year I cut
back on courses and I'm gonna work more
out of like home do more mentoring and
coaching click online stuff and you know
some more product that kind of thing
mm-hmm what kind of products you selling
well you know I get the band's the get
you so bad
and those are you know everyone smile
get them in stock and it's not something
I have con
the constant flow of because I have to
order them family made I've got a a
sling ding you know that's for an AR
it's kind of like a modular monopod I
got books I got uh what kind of product
do I have not a lot not not as I'll have
like a store you know t-shirt yeah yeah
yeah in case somebody wants to get you
scope yes and that's what the teachers
get use of that that's one of them get
your blaze off dog get you blaze on
thank you when you were you uh like I've
seen some of your stuff where you've got
like blaze ops your 45s rapid alright
yeah are those like them available well
those everyone smiled you collaboration
got it with a guy you know and so I did
one with them because I know someone
that needs a blazer 5 only 25 of those
were made we got to do another run yeah
yeah well I'm collaborating right now
with another company to do a different
one so it's it's it's very fledgling
right now it's in its infancy but but
I've done uh like a knife you know a
night by one company I've done three
different guns different gun companies
working on another one right now it's
just good collab you know build
partnerships with companies for sure yep
sometimes they work well sometimes
either done yeah well not everybody out
there is there's some there's some slimy
[ __ ] out there is indeed yeah
uh I mean look dude it's been it's been
over two hours yeah but so all the stuff
that you're doing right now you're
getting after you got you got um t max T
max ink.com yep that's where people go
to hook up with your training which I
looked at your schedule you said you're
not doing as much yeah your calendars
yeah already hacked it's not much more
than two courses a month though you know
for the reef for the year but you do
them in different locations yes people
can go on there you know and what I was
gonna say was you're like hey look you
know people can shoot and and there's
you know thousands and thousands of guys
that are really good with pistol and
then you kind of mentioned but you know
it's a methodology but also look I
instruct humanity
leadership all time that's what I do and
there's a bunch of people that teach
leadership yep there's a there's a
communication skill set that you have
right where what you can do is convey
the message properly that so people
actually absorb it right that's the
important part
I'd like to say that you know the big
thing about teaching is you have to be
the right person is gonna say the right
thing to the right person at the right
time it's important to know what to say
but more important to know what not to
say and the message has to be palatable
too
and then you know it has to resonate
with resonate and be relevant but yeah
man it's I love doing that I love the
teaching thing and those courses are for
everybody yes yeah I do
open enrollment course no they're
forever so I get the full gamut of
people I think most of them are sold out
this year I think the only one open I
have a woman's course in a beginners
course I've never taught either round
where is every gainers course because
every Charles is signing up they're both
they're both in North Carolina 500
Carolina Charles yep I'll bring my party
mix right so we got so we got d-max
ink.com then you also have combat
strength right training and it's a
combat strength training EUCOM yeah
which is where and you got look uh one
of the reasons I didn't talk a bunch
about this is because you've got awesome
videos online you talk about what you're
doing you show what you're doing right
you got those courses clearly your based
on and I hate to use the word functional
right because everyone you know right
but if go and look at your your stuff
what you're doing you can see clearly
these are drills skills conditioning
based on being able to function in a
wide variety of environmental situations
yeah the functional thing is overused
and abused I'll say it's exercise for
the real world maybe I think that what
we do or what I put together it's all
about life saving your ass kicking you
know those are essentially and I put a
lot of free information out there on my
institutions amidst agreement yeah insta
and and the workout stuff that I put on
there it's not
hubris or gloating it's it's about hey
this is a power day example because guys
will buy my programming and if they run
out of curriculum or ideas they could
just go back and say alright power they
strike they speed quickness all right
yeah those are good ideas yeah so man
it's it's a great freaking platform and
that's what I use it for information no
nope so those are the two Tmax ain't
calm you've got combat strength training
calm
you got a facebook which is t max inc
you've got your Instagram yet would you
say no Bologna hope he calls it the
Graham capital capital G per gram and
and yours uh you do all kinds of you the
other thing you do you talk about theirs
which is which is awesome is you give
people a little heads-up on you know you
are your own protection yes yeah alright
so so they said no sermons yep so
teaching people a man there's some
things to think about
yep and everybody could use those things
right because the world is not a happy
peaceful place all the tonight yep and
it's really easy to lose track those
echo you got anything then I got a my
youtube channel to Pat Mac YouTube
channel oh yeah and those are great
shooting drills you got its me off every
time I see it cuz I know you're like a
either at your gym at your house at your
range and I'll of course live in
California it's in a city yes so you can
only you know luckily I get to shoot my
bow but I'm not cracking off rounds out
my back your time I see you right live
in a fast roping cracking off rounds I
get so pissed I'm like well I'm moving
to North Carolina
yeah come on free America we gotta go
no your bicep like what what's the
status on it's good I mean if you know
like if you were to look at me
armed arm comparison one smaller than
the other and there's a big scholar on
you know well you said it it tore on
them on the model ah so DBS surgery they
yes yeah yeah
it was very freaking meatball surgery
army vs the Uni euro private they gave
that to like a doctor the stars gnarly
it's all keloid it's like that why you
know yeah it's yeah but it's a 502 world
for this eat or each yeah we have my
operated on yeah yeah the tendon the
right yeah that's different yeah but it
works them yeah yeah I'll get all my
surgeries because I've had a bunch of
them there everything's good man I'm
feeling pretty good but I attribute that
to how I train and I take care of myself
so I work out pretty freakin smart a
little more tentative now because I'm 55
freakin years old when it comes to like
mix it up grappling free you know that
kind of thing I don't need to get jacked
up while training it's called Fitness
not brokenness the other thing is I got
my own podcast right on a university a
badass that's right yeah that's right
cool with CJ and what CJ's deal he's the
metal motivator so he used to be a
preacher yeah so we've got a pretty good
kid dynamic cuz he's got a gift of
oratory bro I mean like I couldn't jack
his jaws and he makes religion cool too
but he's like a metalhead right yeah
yeah yeah his moniker online is the
metal motivator right on yeah right oh
that's funny you sound better we often
you guys put out that podcast not
offered enough like once a month and a
half mmm something like that yeah but
it's fun it's all upbeat you know just
yeah positive messaging and stuff like
that right oh man right on anything
anything else what do we miss anything
overall I just really I appreciate the
opportunity to be sitting here with you
and like I said man the interweb is a
cool place if you use it right you know
if you use that thing right it's it's
it's a great platform that can help
others and then I get to I get to meet
guys like you you know and you think you
it's like dude
you know you because the interweb just a
feeling I get every time yeah well hey
man thanks for coming on so glad you
came out to California right now you
know thanks for your 22 years on the
grind who they don't taking that taking
us as a nation from the Cold War to the
war on terror you know if it wasn't for
guys like you that that kept those
skills up during all that time that we
wouldn't have been ready for you know
what we faced on the battlefield
so yeah thanks for your service brother
and I could roll that's what I'm talking
about thank you sir right on and with
that Pat Mack has left the building and
we are here should be hopefully let's
just say enthusiastic about improving
our skill sets sure in life agree in all
aspects yes sometimes it might be hard
to figure out of all these skill sets
where am I going to put my focus how do
I prioritize and execute selecting
proper skill sets to improve on yeah
what do you recommend echo Charles bull
I recommend you did too but
interestingly right so Pat Mack he's
over here jumping at all opportunities
to improve his skill sets every training
scenario he was offered jumped on it you
know then when you wind up with a lot of
skill set
yeah very good so many skill sets that
you kind of forget you have them until
the moment comes and you're like oh you
know I can do that right did that yeah
it's true
so don't let get what skill sets you
have until it's time to disarm a
Bulgarian landmine and you I got no
school for that
so don't let you get to not be one of
those skills yes I'm saying it you know
I we didn't even talk about the fighting
skills with Pat Mac for some reason yeah
cuz he's you know he does stand up he
does the jujitsu he his jurors Jim is
primarily an MMA gym actually mm-hmm so
anyways we including including hat Mac
agree what is one skill shet set that
you can utilize just about everywhere
legit it's true so when we train you do
we need to do segi if we're doing G
which we recommend doing G so we are in
fact doing ki so get an origin G that's
the answer
BES Keef actually in the world many
options quality arguably luxury arguably
oh is that kind of a is that is that a
problem for me
I don't know problem when I put on my
rig II am I kind of you're in let me
you're in the lap of luxury for sure it
does feel that way when you put on a
rift key very luxurious yes sir
nonetheless it's functional as well turn
more importantly yeah just so happens to
be made in America that's not there just
so happens and it's made in America
America through the determination yeah
the determination of the people of
America on purpose well you're not happy
instead screen up on purpose there was
people that said it couldn't be done by
the way Pete Roberts told all those
people really yeah and it's cool to make
G's in America unfortunately it's not
cool that you can't wear your gear all
the time you know I guess that's not
right that's not cool I mean you I guess
you pull let me rephrase that you could
wear your gear all the time but you
might get some funny looks at the
supermarket so have you ever worn your
key outside the gym yeah him nauseam
yeah so one time actually me no one time
mm-hmm
where where I was up later then my
lovely wife I didn't want to go in the
room and like disturb her maybe wake her
up or something like that to go get it
jack it was kind of cold so I was
wondering how you got a gr I needed a
jacket scenario what's going on but I
didn't want to disturb so I'm like
looking around for just I don't know
anything I don't want to put a blanket
on myself while I'm on the computer it
seemed Ken I don't know I mean I guess I
could have but it kind of snot
functional you know you don't get in the
way when you're typing you gotta read
anyway
I find the risky I put it on it works
seems safe yeah so that they're there
O's they're sitting there wearing my top
outside of the gym and what we wearing
we were in pants joggers no I don't
shorts I probably was not wearing shorts
if it was cold but good point to be
honest not a good point Fabio because I
wear shorts when it's called ball time
yeah but your legs don't get cold of it
you know that is me you know yeah I
don't know I don't remember but I think
it was pants of some sort all right
nonetheless yes we're getting or Jinky
yes and because you can't wear a geek
unless your echo Charles in your house
don't want to wake up your wife yes most
of the time you don't want to wear Aggie
around if you need pants guess what you
can get jeans origin jeans origin jeans
which are also made 100% in America and
we just released the second version of
the jeans which are the first version
was called the factory jeans they're a
heavy weight heavier weight I guess
technically be a medium weight but we
have now launched the Delta 68 genes
which are light weight people ask are
they what is the word flexible is that
the work yeah stretch stretch yes they
are they're they're they're made to move
you can do a full deep squat workout in
your jeans they're not jeggings though
you know what jeggings are no they're
leggings but jeans oh no no they just
look like jeans but they're leggings oh
so they're not jeggings kind of a
violation of like humanity with that hey
you're the one who said to the stretch
she said the word stretch not meet you
so unless we gotta clarify so Delta 6g8
jeans have some give you know let's just
say that and some giving them their
lounge analogy some freedom of movement
you and do a high kick or something like
this and fine right you're good okay
boom ain't gonna tell 268 jeans are in
the house as it were also
Gers comfortable Jokers for people that
wear John Rogers in the event of you
wearing joggers boom or Jemaine dot-com
that's where you get this stuff also
supplements Jocko our supplements
important they are important and not to
split it and not to get put to a sharp
of a point on it mmm
but it depends what kind of supplements
true true I recommend that you put
supplements that allow you to get after
it at the top of your list
I eat joint warfare yes sir I eat krill
oil super grill joints in the game your
joints aren't in the game you're not in
the game straight up you know discipline
discipline go discipline go pills
discipline go in a can
you're gonna need more protein guess
what you might as well get a protein
that tastes like dessert you don't have
to punish yourself with protein remember
those days if you want an extra protein
it was a punishment it was a punishing
yeah if you want to do good on like you
could get the can you know how like mega
male mass 5,000 I don't know if you read
this morning's a big thousand rupees
5000 yeah it's in a big bag huge thing
but tasted pretty good but I I'm fairly
searching there is like straight-up
sugar and all the stuff and maybe like
technically I might add some protein in
there but it was like 5,000 calories or
something like this yeah was just you
see I'm saying so Molk you don't need to
drink that junk anymore now you can
drink milk mint strawberry mint
strawberry vanilla chocolate and peanut
butter yeah good stuff Dan who also got
warrior Kid milk you can hook that up
for your children why would you give
your children poison
nobody's give them milk I'll tell you
the reason man
short-term versus long-term is
everything everything can be broken down
the short-term versus long-term so you
can even kids poison as it were or these
supremely unhealthy items for short-term
gain to keep them quiet to keep them
from complaining to make to put a
temporary smile on their face you know
why you do it use I don't you think
that's the case man I just think you
don't know you just don't know now yes
you're right you go okay hey I got this
strawberry drink beverage it's gonna
keep my kid quiet make them happy you
don't even know that there's an option
that there's something that could keep
him quiet make them happy and make them
stronger yeah and smarter and better
yeah so you know how like we you or we
whatever we'll discuss that really most
things pretty much everything in life
can be broken down into short-term and
long-term like battles right most of the
time by most I don't know really what I
mean by most but we'll the same most of
the time usually if you choose
short-term it's at the expense of the
long-term usually there are exceptions
every once in a while you get something
that fulfills both short-term and
long-term sushi in my opinion or your
kid monk mmm-hmm that's another
exception short-term gains short-term
sure long-term not only says section but
long-term gains and by the way you can
get all this stuff including Jaco white
tea at the vitamin shop or you can get
everything that we just talked about at
origin Maine the state ma I and e-comm
it's true also chocolate store it's
called chuckle store and this is where
you can get your very own t-shirts very
own rash guard more rash guards more
representative of this path that we're
all on hats hoodies I don't know if I
said hoodies already but they're on
there some women's stuff on there too
real good stuff good way to support and
more importantly good way to represent
yeah it's a good bone of Fiji's when
you're out in the field Oh big time
you're just
Airport you're representing and all of a
sudden someone goes they give you the
nod
they give you the nod and we know if
something goes down we know at least one
person we can count on
yeah they're with some old of Dedes it's
too got attention Jeff course shirt on
you like that we this guy's got my back
you from the game he knows quitting flag
fully also subscribe to the podcast if
you haven't already on your iTunes or
stitcher where ever you listen to it
it's a good benefit to subscribe right
you get the episode right in your look I
don't know if you call it the inbox or
what but you get it on your phone and
also don't forget that we have the
grounded podcast it's true and the
warrior kid podcast and don't forget if
you're if you like the warrior kid idea
you can support one warrior kid named
Aiden who makes soap at Irish Oaks Ranch
calm do we have it up on our site yet
currently we were finalizing some stuff
but I did get my sample of the killer
soap and approved big-time right your
smells kind of good too yeah one of
these flowery ones oh no I dig it here's
the thing I'm not mad at flowery soaps I
am okay I dig it
I fully big it but I am NOT in fact
everyone's well I appreciate a little
know maybe not necessarily flowery but
you know like it's like Irish like a you
know like a refreshing
you see I'm saying unless the killer
soap has a scent to it's mild but an
approved scent to it well like it's tea
tree oil yeah but but there's some
ascent no well it has tea tree oh but
what it actually smells like to me is
mint like a it's just and it's this what
about the visual effect yes yeah that's
a cool so it's so awesome yeah it's good
I knew what that stuff is called killer
so killer so help you get rid of little
Mike nasties yeah that are crawling on
you yeah and the other thing it helps
you do is just goes ahead and it will
help you
stay clean good it's good
that's a good thing to be helped with
for sure also we have a YouTube channel
pretty much you have a youtube channel
no no it's the Wii you're on the YouTube
channel you're going but let's face it
you're on the YouTube channel to youtube
channel that's ours I'm on this
sometimes if it's my youtube channel
then what is it called choco podcasts
okay I guess that kind of and you know
you can see the video version of this
podcast or and see what that Mac looks
like if you don't know already yeah face
it a lot of us newer Eddie what do you
look like same same but if you didn't or
you want to see more whatever whatever
you can see it on the YouTube channel
also X some excerpts on there if you're
interested in that which is kind of cool
we've talked about it before fire fire
explosions okay psychological warfare if
you need a little psychological you can
check that out on all mp3 platforms me
and giving you a little boost little
spot little psychological spot to get
over the moment of weakness flipside
canvas calm my brother Dakota Meyer got
all kinds of cool graphical
representations of the path you can
check that out
if you want to hang up something on your
wall that says discipline equals freedom
we want to hang up the warrior kid code
you can find it there got a bunch of
books the latest is called leadership
strategy and tactics Field Manual
appreciate everyone hooking that up and
now what I see is people posting that
they bought 14 of them for every person
on their team and I'm gonna tell you get
every person on your team moving in that
direction your team is going to rock and
roll so check that one out for the kids
out there we got--we the warrior kid one
two and three and we got for the littler
kids Mikey and the Dragons get those
books get them for even if you even if
it's like your neighbor kid look is your
life gonna be better if your neighbor
kid turns out to be a a loser turns out
to be a drug
turns out to be a non contributing
member of society you want that kid
living next door no you want a warrior
kid living next door why not get your
the neighborhood kids on the warrior kid
path get them all the book get them
liking the dragon so they can overcome
fear let's let's change the culture of
America and make kids warriors I don't
think that's - I don't think that's too
much to ask that's discipline the
freedom feel manual there's a book that
you get for yourself for people that you
know that you want to help them help
yourself to have more discipline because
if you have more discipline guess what
you're gonna end up with more freedom
hence discipline equals freedom field
manual how to get after it and then
there's extreme ownership and that
economy of leadership which are
leadership books for you your team your
business your life check those out we
also have a tional on front which is
leadership consultancy where what we do
is solve problems through leadership
that's what we do go to echelon front
comm for details we've worked with
companies of all sizes all over the
world and that's what we do so check
that out we have EF online which is a
way to train the principles that we
teach an echelon front train them in
your company in your business in your
life online interactive engaging check
that out EF online comm we have the
muster which is our leadership event
leadership seminar leadership gathering
and that this year is in Orlando it is
in Phoenix Arizona and it is in Dallas
Texas every every one that we've done is
sold out and these are gonna sell out
too so if you want to come go to extreme
ownership calm for details and to
register and of course we also have EF
overwatch and EF Legion which is where
we are taking military personnel that
understand the principles leadership
that we talk about all
time taking them and employing those
leadership principles in the civilian
sector so go to EF overwatch comm for
executive leadership go to EF Legion for
frontline leadership and again if you
want to check out Pat Mack he has T max
ink.com and he also has combat strength
training com
he's also on Facebook t max Inc and
Instagram t max Inc if you want to check
out someone that's getting fired up with
blaze Alps check that out and if you
want to hear more from echo and me well
we're also on the interwebs on Twitter
and on Instagram and on your loss frost
balke that cause adequate Charles and I
on that jockey willing and thanks once
again to Pat McNamara for coming on
sharing his wisdom sharing his
experience and more importantly than
that thanks to Pat Mack for his service
and sacrifice holding the line
continuing to pass on knowledge to make
people in every walk of life better and
the same of course goes out to all FETs
and all of our uniformed soldiers
sailors airmen and Marines out there
training and fighting to keep us safe
and free into our police and law
enforcement and firefighters and
paramedics and EMTs and dispatchers and
correctional officers and Border Patrol
and Secret Service thanks for your
service as well which also keeps us safe
thank you for what you do and to
everyone else out there
listen make yourself capable improve
your skills be ready be prepared be be
able to take care of yourself and the
people around you and the way you do
that
is to go out there every single day and
get after it and until next time this is
echo and Jocko out